Four,
three,
two,
one.
Okay,
so I'm on my way over here and I'm
listening to this new radio lab podcast
and then talking about this new
technology that's available.
I'm like,
this is the perfect thing to be
listening to right when I'm coming to
hang out with Eddie Bravo.
Oh No.
There's a website called future of fake
news.com
where they show this new technology on
display.
Well you know how adobe does photoshop
and so they can.
They can adjust images.
They can take 20 to 40 minutes to.
They could do it with 20.
They prefer to do it with 40,
40 minutes of recorded audio of you
talking.
Then they run it through this machine
and they can have you say words you've
never said thinking of you make sounds
that you've never made in those.
In those little sentences.
That's so like you could have a sentence
that.
Yeah,
like you can have a sentence that says
like a,
hey joe,
you want to get something to eat after
the podcast and they can intersect.
Hey Joe,
I got a bunch of transgender hookers and
some heroin.
You want to get something to eat and go
hang out with them after the podcast,
and it would sound exactly like what you
said.
It looks sound exactly like your own
word,
but I'm sure there's going to be experts
that can analyze it and go,
this is,
this is a fraud for now.
What they're essentially saying is this
is,
uh,
the infancy of it.
You have to get like experts to analyze
the audio.
You could see it right there.
They'd synthesized Barack Obama's a
audio and they have them say things that
he never said the,
they have him and George Bush going back
and forth telling jokes to each other
that they never told.
Dude,
I.
can we hear this?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So now can we think you're talking about
find that.
Okay.
See if you can find that.
It might be on their website.
Um,
it doesn't sound good when they're doing
that,
but it's in its infancy,
but it sounds like them talking,
it just,
it sounds a little edited,
you know,
it's not flowing together.
Right.
But apparently they're able to break
down faces to the point where say there
were saying that like if Jennifer
Aniston goes to China and she does a
commercial for something,
what they can do is have Jennifer
Aniston talk for a period of time and
they figured out how her,
her voice moves and they take all these
images of her face and they can
manipulate it so accurately they can
have someone speaking mandarin Chinese
where all the different,
you know,
different sounds they make and they
could sync up her lips and her movement
and the movement of her face to what it
would look like if she was making those
actual sounds,
which is just amazing.
So then they can have a voice like a
mandarin speaking woman who could speak
in Chinese and you would see the exact
correct movements from Jennifer
Aniston's mouth.
So it wouldn't like,
you know how you watch like a movie
though,
right?
But let's hear,
let's hear it.
Our parties have moved further and
further apart and it's harder and harder
to find common ground.
So what I said in 2004 that there were
no red states,
blue states through the United States of
America was
wrong.
So you could tell by the lips in that
one.
Yeah.
Have you looked at his lips?
It looked fun,
but that's just now like what's it going
to be like in a year?
What's it going to be like in five
years?
And this is.
This is what they're saying is that
we're,
we're looking at now is the future of
fake news.
They're going to be able to recreate
people saying things that they never
said and it's going to be impossible for
you to tell the difference.
So how can that be used for the
Illuminati?
How could it be used for anybody?
That's the problem.
Anybody can see the problem is that good
enough DC,
oh now we can do this.
I don't know.
It's hard.
It's hard to say what would be good
because you never know what the end
result of anything is going to be.
When someone creates some sort of a mind
bending world changing technology like
that.
It only could be for bad because it's a
lie.
It's not going to be alive.
Whatever it comes out of their mouth,
it's going to be a lie so that there's
no way that could be good.
Yeah,
but see what it is is the consequences
of technologists pushing boundaries.
So the problem is it's not.
Their intention is not initially to do
something bad.
That's one of the interesting things
about the radio lab.
Probably funny.
Hold on because the radio lab podcast
talk to the technologists and they
confronted her with it and it's very
uncomfortable to watch this lady be
confronted with the idea like what if
this is used for evil?
Like what if it's used for fake news and
you could tell that they don't.
They're not even thinking about that.
Hardly all they're trying to do is
figure out how to do something that
nobody else can do.
Like when someone comes up with the
technology,
if you can come up with some sort of a
voice manipulating technology like that
or a visual manipulating technology,
you've got to realize there's a bunch of
other people that are probably closing
in on something like that too,
and it becomes this mad race to get
something done and to make a shit ton of
money.
If you have something like that that
could be potentially worth who knows
ungodly sums of money.
I'm just trying to figure out a way you
could use that for good to go away.
The one thing that they were saying is
you could take recordings of Einstein.
There's hours and hours and hours and
hours of recordings of Einstein.
You could create a visual Einstein and
you could have a three d technology
perhaps or virtual reality technology
where you're hanging out having a
fucking conversation with Einstein and
now step one.
Right?
Step two is some sort of a neural
interface with virtual reality where
instead of just looking at it through
goggles,
it's going into your mind in some sort
of a way.
It's interfacing with the very neurons
and the very,
your visual cortex.
It's showing you images that you're,
you know,
you wouldn't really be seeing for sure.
It would be great for brainwashing
though.
Yeah.
Oh,
for sure.
That's a no brainer.
That's for sure.
Because we're brainwashed,
but they like fake news.
Just like you said,
the thing is perfect.
No one gets out alive with this shit.
So this is the thing.
There's one thing that might be
fascinating about it is there's gonna be
no control,
like everyone's going to be able to
eventually use something like this and
they said that it would require like
painstaking step by step a person going
over the data to see if they could
figure out what was manipulated and they
think they could find like 75 percent of
the ones that have been manipulated
right now find the fake ones.
But the problem is the amount of time
that it takes to do that is astounding.
Crazy.
It's an.
It's people to people time like you
have.
You have to be sitting there like going
over it,
looking at what is this?
Check that out,
go back.
What's this number right here?
Why is this off?
What's going on here?
Okay,
mark that move on and they have to like
do this over and over and over again.
They'll lifts her anomalies.
Look for some sort of evidence that has
been manipulated by a digital source or
by some sort of a digital control,
a phone or a computer or something like
that.
I think it'll be easy to tell from the
beginning.
Maybe.
What do you mean?
How good are photoshops?
Like the Photoshop,
Steve,
how good are some of his photoshops and
this dude is just having fun.
Well,
how about that?
Photoshop of A.
I think it's Neil Armstrong where he's
standing on the moon and if like there's
a shot,
there's a shot of him looking down.
It's like a selfie and then there's the
earth in the background and they proved
that's a photo,
a photo shop already.
I mean they could just run it through
shit.
Just basic shit.
And you could see that it was cut in.
Well there was definitely some
manipulation of photos for press use
this.
Not just that was.
That was 1969.
Well,
they did it before that even they did it
with the Gemini Space Program when we
did a defending that picture.
No,
it's good.
it's real.
Nobody defends that picture.
Well,
I don't know if they do or don't,
but the craziest one is Michael Collins
because Michael Collins,
you can prove it.
The Gemini 15 picture,
they took a test photo of him like in
some sort of a warehouse where they
would strap him up with a harness and
they're showing them how to utilize this
equipment and then they blocked all that
shit out and reverse the image and try
to pretend he was doing a spacewalk.
Never seen it.
Uh,
and maybe maybe.
I mean I've seen so much on the moon.
This one's the best one.
Not Even the moon.
It's just Michael Collins.
But you should see it because it's like,
wait a minute,
why the fuck would they do that?
Like they took a photo.
This is a 100 percent.
This is not speculation.
They took a photo of him at a test
facility where they would prepare
themselves for walking on the moon.
The one on the left is then preparing.
See,
you could tell he's in a harness,
there's a bunch of equipment around and
he's hanging onto this thing and they're
pulling them like with this harness that
he's attached to.
And then the next one it says it's a
spacewalk.
It's the same exact image.
They just blacked it out.
They just took all the stuff that was in
the background,
all the equipment and all the bullshit
that's kind of a blurry copy.
See you can find a better copy of it.
But what they did was they made a fake
photo of a guy in space that photo's not
real.
That's a photo of him in the test suit
and they just reversed it and blacked
out the background.
They could get away with stuff like that
back then,
man.
It wasn't,
that's a better picture of it.
There you got to get a,
that's a good,
uh,
representation.
It's
just what,
what they did was take all that shit.
What they did was unquestionably
deceptive.
So the question is how much of that did
they do?
Oh,
come on.
Well,
that's the question.
The question is,
it's even hard for the most hardcore of
skeptics,
not even the most hardcore skeptics.
They're like,
yeah,
I'm on the fence about that moon thing.
You know,
I'm.
No one's really.
No one's really saying yes.
He went to the moon.
Now even like Mick Westville shut up
about that.
You know,
there's Niki.
We'll.
I don't think you're right at all.
I think he would definitely argue that
we went to the moon.
Well,
he's getting paid for that.
So they come in and he's got to.
I mean the dude,
the dude backs up every official story.
Yeah,
but people do that.
Not necessarily because they're getting
paid.
They do it because that's the mindset
they're in.
They're in this mindset like we were
talking about someone else before the
podcast website.
He makes money on his website.
That's what I'm talking very little
money to be made of bumping things.
That's not the motivation for doing it
when you're a multimillionaire from
video games.
I mean,
he made a shit ton of money from,
from selling video games.
He was like a some sort of a programmer
in video games and then he has a good
time debunking things,
but he has an official story
mentalities,
what I would call it,
where no matter what,
like there's people that are objective
and there's people that are debunkers
and he's a debunker and it doesn't
necessarily mean he's wrong about a lot
of stuff,
but it does mean that he goes into
things with the intention to debunk and
the intention to almost always gravitate
towards an official stores.
Every single t he blended.
He believes Harvey Oswald acted alone.
Yeah.
That's a goof.
Come on,
man.
That one's goofy.
He believes tower seven collapsed at
free.
Fall speed because the fires.
There's a lot of people that believe
that.
Unfortunately I'm not a fucking
engineer.
I would like to know whether or not it's
possible to burn a building so bad
inside that it does collapse like that.
It's impossible.
I don't know if that's true.
None of it.
All you have to do is talk to engineers
and architects.
I've talked to them.
You could.
You could hear them.
No,
there's no architects that it outside of
Nist,
a government agents and there's no
architects fighting for,
uh,
I'm trying to debunk the tower seven.
There's none in every account.
I don't know if that's true to you.
I don't know if you know that,
but there's got to be some architects
and engineers that don't think that that
building fell because it was demolished.
No.
Well,
if you understand how it,
there's about 100,000
architects and engineers and the
associations like the American
Association of Architects in here.
There's about a hundred thousand and
Richard Gauge.
He's one of them and he didn't know
anything about.
He thought it was a,
it wasn't an inside job.
It took him years and then he didn't
really know about tower seven.
Most of them don't know about power
seven.
What he does now,
he discovered it and what he does now,
we'll just go from convention to
convention,
sitting 15 architects down at a time and
boom,
about 99 percent of them.
They all believe that.
They didn't even know there was a third
tower.
It was not in the media that much.
They basically ignored.
It's crazy.
I think by this time everybody knows
about tower so they still don't know.
Most people don't know,
but they don't.
You don't run on a mainstream media.
How could anybody.
People have talked about it enough
online to the point now more than ever,
but still my now more than ever,
yes.
They go to hear about that tower seven
thing,
but they don't really know the details.
They just kind of just know about it.
You know?
You ever see the video that shows the
full collapse,
which takes a lot longer.
She the first collapsed.
It was the top of the thing falls into
the center and that's the elevations
they explain architects and engineers.
I've sat with them.
I'm a structural engineer,
but you tell them this is what if
someone told you,
if someone told you there's 85 columns
that hold up tower shoving and if
someone told you about structional
engineer,
told you,
would you think he was crazy or would
you believe him?
If he said,
and it makes sense.
I mean it's common sense.
The only way you're going to get a
building to come down like that,
any building,
any structure,
is you have to blow up all 80 comps the
same time.
Otherwise they won't go down like that.
To me,
that's common sense to someone who
believes that government agencies have
said,
no,
that's not true.
One column went and then it spiraled out
of control because of fires.
When you talk to structural engineers,
I've had,
I've had Richard Gauge on my podcast
wife.
Every time it comes back,
he gets more.
He just piles on more because all I
gotta do is sit them down.
They don't know.
Nobody knows.
That's the truth.
CSE ever debated someone who's like an
opposing viewpoint,
but it will debate on structural.
I know nobody's backing up.
This is what he's teaching them would
though,
because when they look into it,
it's common sense.
Anybody knows you got to,
so you think that they know that it's
not true.
They think they think that power tower
seven was an inside job and they don't
want to debate it because they can't.
When you really think they think that.
I say that again,
so you think that people that are
debunking it,
so like if,
if he's got this opinion,
there's no architects and engineers
debunk it had already looked into that.
That's already been,
that's already been done.
And set texts and engineers just
disagree.
Come on man.
You don't think there's any people to
find the video?
Find a video of a real.
I mean it's got a government agency,
Jamie,
see if you can that,
but doesn't that make sense?
What is sort of a,
an engineer told you,
uh,
struck a dude who build skyscrapers told
you to your face?
Like I've been told to my face.
They said the only way that,
and you see it on video engineer after
engineer,
after engineer.
Are they all crazy?
The engineer,
engineer after Ingenico?
It's impossible when you look into it,
it's impossible for a building to
collapse like that unless all 80 columns
are blown up at the same time we,
we've covered this,
but here's,
it's common.
I don't know anything about engineering.
I don't know if you have diesel fires to
get out of control.
If it weakens the entire.
Where it just collapses
like that,
I don't know if you have,
you have guests all the time that are
experts in fields that you're not
experts in,
but when you sit here just find out
sometimes they're wrong.
Unfortunately.
Sometimes they would ramble about some
stuff and then they find out that
they're making some of it up or this is
some of it does happen,
but as an engineer,
a guy who builds,
understand this,
doesn't it make sense?
Jamie?
Does that make sense?
Google,
like try to figure out like who resists
architects and engineers?
Like what is it written down?
I'm reading right now an article from
the Boston Globe that talks about truth
is nine slash 11 and Richard Gauges
talked about and I think they they're
going to hold on that might have
interviewed him in and I'm trying to
figure out what this is,
what they're talking about.
There's got to be some artists that have
had a conversation or a debate with
someone who believes in you couldn't
possibly have fallen any other way.
Maybe they're out there.
Here's the thing.
I don't know,
Shit like I don't know how my fucking
computer works.
I don't know.
How do you know anything that
constructs.
How do you know anything?
A lot of Shit,
you know a lot,
but I know,
but if somebody wanted to argue with me
about the components and how they worked
on a laptop,
I would have to let go.
Yes,
you're probably right after to talk to
some computer engineer who's going to
tell me the actual reality of it.
Build buildings.
I've had a mom I'm sure,
but I just can't believe that the people
that build buildings think it's an
inside job,
so.
Okay.
What if we said,
okay,
what have been pretty impressive if 90
percent.
That was pretty impressive.
It was a 50 percent would be impressive.
Exactly.
Fifty percent would be impressed.
It's about in the nineties.
I don't know if that's right.
So I don't know where you getting that
number.
I'm getting it from Richard Gage,
who's the head of architects and
engineers was not 11 truth.
They add another couple of understand
but know.
But he might be a little biased,
right?
I mean,
if he's the head of architects and
engineers from nine,
11 truth and he tells you that 90
percent of the architects and engineers
out there think it's an inside job,
it might be a little biased.
I don't know if that's true and I don't
think you do necessarily either.
I think we're.
We're just guessing.
I believe it.
I would love to see.
I would love to see an architect or an
engineer that disagreed with him,
talked to him about it and go over the
data because until that happens,
I don't know what the fuck they're
talking about.
No,
nobody argues with them.
Nobody does.
That's got to be.
There's got to be someone who debunks
that guy.
Everybody debunks.
Everybody know they definitely a smear
campaign.
Are you kidding?
But,
but isn't a smear campaign or is it just
that they're saying things that he's
saying that aren't correct?
Not just him.
He's just.
I understand it's common sense date
maybe.
Okay.
It's just bright,
but I don't know.
I don't know anything about making
buildings.
I don't know anything about what it
takes for a building to collapse.
I don't know.
Totally.
I don't know either.
Maybe it got hot.
I believe not just hot,
it's diesel tanks were in the basement.
I want to believe that.
I want to believe that it fires made it
hot and I don't want to believe they
blew it up because that's fucking scary.
I wonder,
want to believe the fire.
If a fire is in a basement and the fire
has diesel fuel and it's burning it,
some insane temperature in this fucking
shit.
Loads of diesel fuel down there.
I wonder what effect that has.
I don't know.
Do you?
Uh,
I,
I'm pretty sure based on my life's
experience,
that that's not going to bring down a
building fuel life experience based on
common sense.
It's common sense that,
yeah,
for building the building's going to
fall at free fall speed,
boom.
Like that.
If a engineer after engineer after
engineer at some point,
I'm going to believe them at some point.
I'm not going to understand it,
but I don't.
I don't know if you'd necessarily looked
into engineers at disagree.
I know there's a smear campaign.
They're okay,
but have you looked into the engineers?
There's none.
There's none,
there's no doubt.
There's no documentary,
there's no documentary mentoring.
Find a documentary if they have to make
a documentary for it to make sense.
What was that?
What if it's an article?
What if it's a peer reviewed paper?
What if it's some sort of.
Those are all,
dude,
that's a smear campaign.
There's that side.
There's the elite that don't want this
out.
And then there's people trying to get
the truth out.
So the elite have the control of the
media.
So how are you going to.
They have paid shills or you don't think
you think that they dropped.
They would have dropped the ball big
time.
Like earnest byner in 1987 for the
browns.
It would have dropped the ball if you're
not,
if you don't have paid shills online.
Strategically pushing the agenda.
Come on.
Okay.
Were we about to pull up?
There's a bunch of fake shit on him.
What?
Jamie?
As I was stuck on this Richard Gauge
thing that I was trying to debunk,
see if anybody's debunking him.
Uh,
I'm looking at.
He's just a character.
I'm looking around.
I'm just looking around.
The Boston Globe article says that
there's a small vocal subset of people
of engineers that are with this Richard
Gauge Guide read.
I've never read that.
It was like some overwhelming number.
Just keep.
Keep stirring.
It's.
It's hard because it's fun.
It's exciting.
It's exciting to think that there's some
sort of a gigantic ball of super
geniuses that run the world and they
decided to blow up tower seven.
You know what's funny about the moon?
Fucked ourselves.
Jesus.
Talk about the.
You know,
what's crazy about the moon?
What is the hardest shit ever
accomplished?
The greatest by the human race.
The greatest accomplishment was landing
on the moon.
Right?
Right.
So you would think,
holy shit balls.
I don't know what.
Listen.
Okay.
But let's just at the time.
At the time the Internet is the biggest.
Okay.
But I'm just talking about like a
physical achievement.
Three dudes,
they got shot up in a rocket that were
in a,
like a orbiter and then the orbiter shot
out the lunar,
like the lamb,
and then it lands.
They played golf,
Went Dune bug riding,
did donuts in the sand.
They get take pictures.
They get back
in,
take off dock with that orbiter and then
fly back.
That's the hardest she'd ever.
No one died.
Can you imagine?
Can you imagine that second mission,
six months later they did it again when
when they had to break the news that
they were going to use different
astronauts because every mission they
use different astronauts.
Wouldn't you think they would like a
show like have the same star over and
over.
The three dudes have pulled it off.
Keep doing it.
They do know.
You're kidding.
They did it before.
Yeah,
but they don't want to keep doing it.
What the fuck you want me?
What if.
What if I got it?
Thank God.
What if they were planning on using buzz
Aldrin and Neil Armstrong,
but they just fucking got an ego shit.
They started going to clubs and like
they want to renegotiate their contract
because they probably went to the moon
for like,
you know,
$70,000.
You know what I mean?
They've got that government check that
go.
We'll put you on the second album on the
second it just like the record business.
You know what I mean?
My bachelor's now album,
we make that much.
Of course they say,
listen,
we'll get you on that second,
on the second and third.
Land means how much money you're gonna
make you're gonna.
Come back,
you're gonna.
Be famous.
You can be fucking doing all sorts of
press.
Think about the bitches.
Think about the coke.
All that shit.
They probably got blowed out and got too
cocky and wanted to renegotiate.
Oh my God.
And then NASA said,
we just got to go with some new dudes.
They made $8 per diem.
When Uncle Sam folks,
you raw dog,
he uses sand.
Uncle Sam uses broken class on his dick.
When you guys went to the moon,
why wouldn't you think there was enough?
That dude in the middle,
the dude in the middle,
in the middle,
didn't actually,
was hovering in an orbiter.
He was hovering in an orbiter and they
landed some little piece of shit.
A Lunar Lander would have the land and
then they took and they show.
The only time I ever,
they got one shot of it taken off and
whatever was filming it followed it all
the way up,
but who was the official story?
There was a live remote controlled.
That's what they said that they could
control from for.
From Houston,
for sure.
That works,
dude.
I couldn't get my phone to work on the
moon.
Landings are so God damn ridiculous.
Oh fuck.
There's video of them like just maybe a
100,000
feet in the air and they like filming
it,
making it look,
you know,
there are many emulating.
What the fuck come on.
That video stream.
That's a damning.
The explaining what they were doing.
Well the video says that they're saying
they're at 30,000
miles out.
That's what they're saying.
Something like that.
Halfway to the moon,
that would like a 125,000
miles away from Earth.
So halfway halfway to and make it look
like never far away.
So you know,
if they look out their window,
that little circle or whatever shape,
maybe it was a rectangle,
whatever the window it,
the entire earth fills up all the glass
of course.
Because you're like still.
Well it's.
You got to remember they blocked out all
the other windows.
That was what was in damning about it.
What's damning about it is that they've
got this camera setup where they're
filming the blackness of the interior of
the cabin and the circular window and
it's circular windows supposed to
represent earth.
This little slice of earth with clouds
on it and shit and the blend that kind
of stands still trying to create the.
I don't know if that's real.
See,
I've looked at that a hundred times.
It might've just been lucky.
This is exactly what I think more than
anything more more likely.
It was just like,
yeah,
that's fake.
And now that the watch,
this is what you could see.
You can see,
oh this is just you gotta.
You gotta go to the one where it shows
the actual fake footage.
This is the actual video is not going to
show the full thing where they pull away
and you see the guys manipulated the
dampers and pulling the things off the
wall.
The new reveals what it reveals that
they're in low earth orbit,
that they're not really
just looking at Hawaii.
It's like the little hole and they're
focusing on a little island.
Google Bart Sabril
is.
I had A.
I had dinner with this gentleman back in
the day.
He's very nice guy and he's the guy that
wrote a funny thing happened on the way
to the moon and he's absolutely
convinced that they never went to the
moon.
He was a not a dumb guy.
I had an interesting conversation with
him.
He's fully onboard and absolutely
committed and not,
not that they couldn't do it or that
they,
uh,
they couldn't get the footage of it,
but that they faked the whole thing.
Like they never even did.
Everyone went out there.
Some people think that they couldn't
film it.
They went there but they couldn't film
it.
So these,
this fake film of that.
But that there was other ways to track
whether or not they went there.
There's some people that believe that,
and then other people believe.
No,
no,
no.
It's all fake.
It's all fake from the jump.
They shot them into low earth orbit.
They float around in low earth orbit and
then drop back down.
I believe that.
I believe it was.
It's just a scam.
They're just making money and they're.
And they're showing.
That was a distraction for the va from
the Vietnam War.
All six missions during Richard Nixon
administration.
They did one every six months with
different astronauts.
No one got hurt.
No one died.
Are you kidding me?
You ever see the video footage from the
first man in space?
The video footage,
the first manned space is so entirely
fake.
It's fucking hilarious.
Guy.
Russia?
No,
the guy from Russia,
the Russian guy,
he did go into space,
but they didn't have a fucking camera
crew inside the capsule with them.
There's like opposing lights and
different like you could see like if
there's a distance between the guy,
but it's so fake.
It's always been propaganda.
Put up Google fake video footage of
first man in orbit.
What is it?
What was the Russian cat's name?
The first dude that went into orbit.
But uh,
they have a video footage of him inside
his car.
Oh,
leg room was all like tech was one of
the first leg lock guys ever.
Right.
You had to watch your shit with him.
He would sambo the shit out of your
legs.
Remember there was like a few leg locks
back in the day.
Just a few.
Yep.
No,
you know,
the craziest thing I found out I thought
heel hooks for sure were legal and sambo
and apparently they're not even legal
and samba.
Oh my God.
They just do straight ankle locks and
bars and it was because of the shoot and
calf cranks.
They all wear shoes and no heel hooks
and samba.
That's crazy.
What do you think about shoes?
She be allowed to wear shoes were either
at fighting or in grappling.
No,
no.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think gloves too,
but then I'm a broken record with that.
Did you find it video of just find fake
video from Diane face tends to my work
shoes.
Fuck it.
Problem is mma like kick you and that
goes in your eye.
What is this footage?
No,
no,
no.
This is the moon landing.
So Soviet moon landing.
Now,
first man in orbit.
Um,
it's inside the cockpit.
It's like a NASA faking a earth.
NASA first man and,
or regression.
Not just put NASA faking or what was the
guy's name?
Who was the first,
uh,
first man in orbit.
What's near Gagarin.
Okay,
so go Yuri Gagarin a video.
You could see the video.
So he climbs into this thing.
He takes off and then see if you can
find the first person like staring at
him.
There's a bunch of it where it's like,
so clearly not really happening.
It's all fake,
man.
They're all faking it.
The Russians are faking it.
They're all,
they're all doing it together where
there's no real cold war.
But there was a,
a,
some sort of a
video on the analysis of that saying
that there's light sources in there.
There wouldn't be a light source inside
that cabin that you'd be able to film
with and how far away with the camera
have to be to capture this and they had
these big ass clunky cameras and it
wasn't that kind of space.
Think about,
think about TV and the movies when they
were born.
What were they ever about?
Like what's really going on?
You know,
I dream of Jeannie was right away.
It's right away.
It's total bullshit right away from day
one.
It's never.
There was never a show about what life
really is.
It was always bullshit right from the
start,
right from the Getgo,
propaganda.
They didn't create TV for entertainment.
You kidding me?
Oh,
let's entertain them.
CVC,
it's not like one super genius wants to
create something called TV and then they
use that tv to manipulate the world.
What happens is one super genius figures
out a way to take a visual image and
projected into millions of different
televisions at the same time.
Who's paying this?
Hold on a second because he's a
technologist,
so he figures out how to do it.
They start things through this and then
the powers that be realize what kind of
manipulation you could get out of
something like that where you could show
the news every night and presidential
addresses and then they started using it
for their own good,
but it wasn't created to control
people's brains.
It was created because people have this
inherent desire to constantly innovate
and make better and better shit.
We don't even know why we do it,
but we're fucking obsessed with it.
So these technologists,
to create it,
they.
They're so far smarter than any of the
people that use it and manipulate
people.
The people that created the ones that
actually understand how to make a
digital signal with your phone stream
live and periscope and a guy who was in
New Zealand can look at it in real time
while you're talking about something
would be a good idea for the Illuminati
that seek people like that out and hire
them.
Wouldn't that be a good move?
That's definitely a good hell yeah.
You go after those dudes wearing a man,
I think black male.
Um Damn.
You got them.
Companies work directly with military
and they get billy to military contracts
to make all kinds of shit they always
have,
whether it's computer stuff,
whether it's surveillance equipment,
what I mean,
there's lucrative contracts like that
was the big thing about the Iraq war,
right?
Like everybody was terrified of the fact
that you had this guy who was the ceo of
Halliburton,
which is a company that cleans up after
we blow shit up and that guy becomes the
vice president and then they start
getting these giant no bid contracts to
clean shit up after we blow it up.
Like the money involved in something
like that is insane,
right?
You're talking just hundreds of millions
of dollars just flowing like water,
right?
It's just constantly flowing.
So if you think about that,
you think about that.
That's going to be the case with
everything.
If they have the kind of money to throw
that way towards the Afghan war,
what,
what kind of black ops money do they
have to make those jets unlimited?
Those stills crazy.
Fucking stealth.
Generally as much trillions are
constantly missing in the Pentagon at
back in right before nine slash 11.
It was two point 3 trillion missing from
the Pentagon.
Literally a couple days before,
but yeah,
the day before Donald Rumsfeld,
everyone knows about that,
but like now I'm done.
Now it's like,
oh,
17 trillion are missing two,
two point 3 trillion was bad.
Where's all this money going?
Exactly.
Trillions.
Yeah.
This is where it's at,
but here's what you're saying is not
crazy.
Like people are listening to this.
There's a lot of people that are
listening to this that have never heard
this before,
and they think,
well,
this is crazy.
These guys are just making shit up.
This is some loony fucking left wing
conspiracy theory.
Yay.
You guys think that the government was
in on this and that it was all a scam to
hide the fact that they'd stolen
trillions of dollars,
but they really did have a press
conference and it's really available
online and Donald Rumsfeld really does
look straight at the camera and he
really does say they're missing
trillions of dollars.
Two point 3 trillion,
trillion trillion.
That's a thousand billion and then the
day
nine slash 11 hits a plane or a bomb
blows up a small little section of the
Pentagon where all the people that are
auditing the Pentagon,
the Accounting Office blows up and
everyone coincidence,
bro.
It's a total coincidence that she could
really happen.
Listen to me,
man.
No one would ever kill someone for as
little as two point $3,000,000,000,000.
That's not enough money to get people to
kill people.
It's just not.
People need more money to kill people.
People kill people for like 50,
except she gave so really shitty guy who
would kill somebody for like a thousand
dollars.
Shit is so corrupt and it's always been
listening to Donald Rumsfeld talk about
this.
Oh,
how dare you talk her over guy.
See if he could find the actual video of
him talking because it's pretty
fascinating.
It's just a couple minutes.
Donald Rumsfeld.
Yeah.
That's a lot of money down.
Whereas that carries a shitload of them.
Where'd it go,
son?
Um,
yeah.
This is,
that's not the full video of him
actually saying it,
but nine slash 11.
Donald Rumsfeld,
trillion guaranteed a bunch of no one
ever talked about it again.
That was great.
The second one,
boom.
What's crazy is it really didn't get
brought up after that.
Let's listen to it on reinsurance.
Same time.
$7,000,000,000,000
in transactions.
Two point 3 trillion,
2000,
one 10th of September ends according to
some estimates.
We cannot track two point
$3,000,000,000,000
in transactions.
Two point 3 trillion with a t.
The very next day,
according to the accounting offices were
destroyed in the Pentagon to two point 3
trillion was never brought up again.
Who's more gangster than that?
They got they go,
dude,
we just got to say something because you
could take the trillions,
but we got to make.
We got to admit it and then everyone's
gonna.
Forget about it.
What did people say to that?
That's one of the one,
one of those ones where what does
people.
What do people say to the idea that the
plane would hit the perfect spot to hide
the two point three trillions of dollars
in debt to for you,
for someone to know,
to admit to themselves,
they'll say,
everybody will admit the government is
corrupt,
but when something gets brought up,
they're always believe in the government
side.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
but this one doesn't even have a side.
Here's the thing.
Still watched that and know that was
fishy shit.
Nine slash 11.
I don't trust it and everything.
Every now you got to look at nine slash
11.
If you see that and you don't look at
nine slash 11,
what?
Skeptical eyes there.
You're hypnotized.
Well,
that alone is one of those Arsenio Hall
segments.
Things that make you go,
hmm,
come on man.
Cool.
You're going to trust.
You know you're doing like if you were
doing business with this organization
and then you saw a speech by
the chairman of that organization and he
just said,
we're missing a $55,000,000,000.
Would you still want a new business with
this guy?
Look at this one.
Trillion's go missing from the military.
Pentagon can account for six point 5
trillion in tax payer cash.
Cash.
No one can but.
But everyone.
The official story,
I believe the official story that they
wouldn't do that.
They wouldn't do that.
Yeah,
they're are corrupt,
but they wouldn't do that.
Yeah,
they're evil.
but they wouldn't do that.
It's like it doesn't make any sense.
The report review,
look at this.
They cannot provide adequate
documentation for how it spent.
Six point 5 trillion.
That is hilarious.
How do they,
how do they not all go to jail?
How nobody.
Nobody's going to jail.
You know,
Illuminati.
Nobody goes to jail.
Your richest.
Fuck I know,
but this is into satanism.
The people that go to people that have
the money that our taxes go to,
like they have it.
Our taxes,
we spend the money or we buy,
we get the money.
We sent it to them.
They have it.
They can't account for six point 5
trillion.
That's so much money.
That's crazy.
That's like he's in the national debt
like 13 trillion or something.
What's the national debt is higher.
I might've made that up.
Yeah,
your trillion.
What do you think it is?
We think the national debt is to have no
fucking I,
it doesn't even matter.
It doesn't matter what the data.
$6,000,000,000,000
and nobody's going to jail.
But what I'm saying is it's half of the,
I think it might be like half a national
debt.
Nobody.
Nobody in the Illuminati goes to the
jail.
That our national debt is 20 point 4
trillion,
which we cannot pay,
but we can't account for six point 5
trillion.
Why even account for it anymore?
Just at this point.
Just fucking.
Just say,
shut up.
Fuck it.
Let's just cross our fingers.
Yeah.
Well there was an article that was
written about,
uh,
the idea that our country was going to
descend slowly into something that's not
on democracy anymore.
And uh,
the argument you would make if you don't
have to account for trillions of dollars
that you make us pay for the argument
would be.
That might have already happened.
Like where it's all about money and
control,
right?
What more money are you going to get
then?
Six and a half trillion dollars,
like if it's really all just about money
and control,
that's a shitload of money and well,
what's the control?
The control is it's rarely discussed
like there's all sorts of outrageous
like transgender people using the
women's room.
Once you're in the Illuminati,
you're above the motherfucking lot.
Nobody's going to jail.
They're all fucking doing crazy shit.
Nobody goes to jail.
Nobody in the Pentagon's going to jail.
Are you kidding me?
No one in the CIA's going to jail.
They're not going to jail.
I understand,
but what's crazy is that no one taught
here a further mysteries.
What happened to thousands of documents
that should be on file but aren't the
ige study found that F A.
I don't know what that is.
Did not document or or support why?
The defense reporting system removed at
least 16,500,
13 of one point 3 million records during
quarter three.
Fiscal year 2015 as a result of the data
used to prepare the fiscal year 2015
egf.
I don't know what that is.
A third quarter and year end financial
statements were unreliable and lacked
and adequate audit trail.
So they just started yanking
transactions and deleting.
I believe them.
Oh,
what else?
Now,
how does that work?
If they,
if they have black ops,
like what we're talking about before.
So if they have like area 51,
which is like groom lake,
you know,
that whole area in Nevada where it's
illegal to even get close to where they
were supposedly develop and stealth
bombers and all that shit.
They did all that stuff out there.
Right?
How much they get and how do they,
how does that money work?
Because that is that where all the
money's going to crazy military
projects.
Like what does a black cop,
you know what I'm saying?
Like if they say black ops,
right?
Is that why they cannot account for
that?
I mean,
isn't that makes sense?
If they're spending trillions of dollars
making these crazy fucking jets and it's
missing.
Yeah.
But,
but is that what it means?
I wonder if that's what it means.
I wonder if it means that this is just
some shit they get to just do whatever
the fuck they want with and they build
these crazy bases and they do whatever.
Sonic jets,
you know what I mean?
Can you imagine the people at the top,
like the islands they have and shit.
Queue management pieces.
They've got pieces of land that we know
nothing about.
Now what Janet budget has it like an
area for classified programs.
So they spent like $59 billion on
classified programs.
Oh,
so the six point 5 trillion is on top of
that.
Yeah.
Maybe classified programs is one level
of top secret and it gets all the way
down to where we deconstruct alien
spacecrafts.
That's like that Robert Lasar type shit.
You ever see that guys videos?
Yeah.
We checked we were 15 years ago and um,
I don't,
I don't know where I am still
fascinated.
That guy's just a little tom because
he's still alive.
Yeah.
Can you imagine him on this podcast?
That would be free cash within the
government.
I think he's really cool.
You know what he's friends with John
Lear and that guy says the most crazy,
crazy sean.
This is his secrets are that there's
people,
there's millions of people on Venus,
there's millions of people on Mars
there.
There's people all over the on every
planet and and they're just not telling
us about that,
but isn't John Lear like,
do you think that it's possible?
I'm just gonna throw this out there.
Do you think it's possible that John
Lear,
who's like some soup,
isn't he a super billionaire character?
He was a former CIA pilot.
He was in the CIA for many years.
Once you're in the cio,
he's in his but isn't any like some
super wealthy businessman.
I don't know how we're thinking about
lear jets.
Jets is like his father created lear
jets,
but is he a super wealthy businessman?
He should be.
I was thinking if I was one of those
guys and I was bored,
I might just be trolling
the fuck out of people telling them
about people on Mars.
That's what he's doing,
what?
He's doing it for fun and and they let
him.
They let him in the Illuminati.
If he does that and he's like,
fuck yeah,
that was already in.
He's probably like,
what you can't deny is things like
Bohemian Grove.
Here's what you can tonight.
Like I'm,
I'm warm.
I'm on the skeptical side of all
conspiracy theories.
I don't get me wrong out there.
I'm not.
I'm not going after anybody.
I'm not trying to indict anybody.
I feel like there's just too many people
are hypnotized to really stop anything.
You can't stop these trillions of
dollars missing.
How are you going to do that?
Who's gonna?
Stop that.
Here's like,
it's,
it's a man.
Too many people are hypnotized.
It's just,
it's,
it's hopeless sometimes,
you know.
Okay.
What I'm saying is that what you see,
these things that you can't deny and one
of the things he can't deny as Bohemian
Grove,
Bohemian Grove is a place where these
leaders and these bankers and he's
elites of the world literally do get
together and put it on fucking robes and
they get in front of a giant stone owl
and they have a like a ceremony and they
burned some sticks.
They burn an effigy.
It's like the,
when Alex Jones was the first guy to
find that like you,
you can criticize Alex Jones all you
want and a lot of it's deserved.
He says a lot of crazy shit and he's a
character and he gets big and theatrical
and it's fun,
but he's exposed some very real shit
that's undeniable.
And one of the things that's undeniable
is that there really is a place called
Bohemian Grove over.
These guys really do get together and
they'd get together and they put on
robes and they worshiped this mole,
the,
our God.
That's something that's been going on
forever.
That's where people thought Alex was a
shield because he would say all this
great nine slash 11 stuff,
9:11
stuff.
And then he would say he would work into
the world's run by Satanic pedophiles,
you know?
So then people go,
okay,
is this shell?
He's a shell.
You know?
It's like saying it's like John Lee or
type shit.
That's what it sounds like.
And that's what it sounded like.
A lot of people that go,
he's a chef,
he's talking about everyone's satanic
and they're all pedophiles.
He,
he's,
he's retarded.
He's a shill.
But uh,
uh,
what do,
what do you know about the Chester
Bennington?
Bennington as suicide?
Um,
I know that he had a,
done a bunch of interviews.
We talked about being raped a bunch of
times when I was young and how fucked up
it was.
I don't know anything other than that.
Damn,
I don't want to talk too much about his
personal life.
No,
it's no personalized.
This is all I'm saying was,
was um,
anytime a dude kills himself.
He's got a bunch of kids.
Yeah.
But when you,
when you talk about,
you know,
um,
Chris Cornell and him were best friends.
Yeah.
You know,
the crystal themself on Chris's birthday
right now,
what?
Chris Cornell and his wife,
they have a foundation called the Chris
and Vicky Foundation and it's all about
helping,
um,
uh,
children that were molested and abused
and a lot of them were like former
pedophile,
a child traffickers trafficky or however
you'd say it.
Um,
and he was really,
really into it.
And this is this,
this is the conspiracy theory.
I don't know,
this is the conspiracy.
It's not with him.
No,
no man,
this is,
this is why shit is getting fucked up as
it has something to do with that.
There's,
um,
he was,
the conspiracy theory is that he was
involved in stopping,
trying to,
you know,
Ashton Kutcher is trying to stop human
trafficking and you know,
how a Corey Feldman,
he got an interview,
he said the biggest problem in Hollywood
is pedophilia.
And then,
and then there's been several people
coming out and the dude from Lord of the
rings,
Elijah Wood,
he says many times he goes,
there's a big problem,
there's an Hollywood and everywhere
really Hollywood and,
and,
uh,
Washington DC.
Do you know that a 800,000
to a million kids get kidnapped a year?
Do you know that?
Is that real?
I don't know.
Look it up.
Where'd you read that?
I don't know.
I mean I somewhere online,
I don't know if it's true,
but it didn't.
Eight hundred to a million kids get
kidnapped her.
And you know what city?
800,000
to a million.
Eight hundred thousand to a million and
you know what?
What?
Where's the biggest city where?
Washington DC.
Really?
Yeah.
Look how many people are kidnapped.
Oh my God.
Two hundred and 3000 children are
kidnapped each year by family members.
800,000
children are reported missing.
Huge.
800,000
dollars a year for missing.
How many of those were recovered?
How many people are kidnapped each day
in the US?
How many children are missing in the
United States?
Click on that.
How many children are missing in the
United States?
According to the National Center for
Missing and exploited children,
roughly 800,000
children are reported missing each year.
In the United States.
That's roughly 2000 per day.
Of those,
there are 115 child.
Stranger abduction cases each year,
so 115 or abducted by children are
abducted by strangers each year,
which means the child was taken by an
unknown person,
so a lot of those.
Most of those people that were abducted
there are taken by family members,
but it's still a shitload of people.
Even if it was 200,000,
even if it was 20,000
kids a year,
get kidnapped,
even if it was 20,000,
isn't that fucking huge?
If it's 121,
it's huge.
20,000.
Yeah.
You know,
and it Sandy Hook was 20 so and there's
800,000
to a million and people are all over
that.
There's,
there's no one's all over it.
Everyone's like,
oh,
that's what comes like.
It's people are aware of it.
That's almost nobody.
Nobody's aware of it,
but so many statistics when it comes to
like how many people die in car
accidents and how many people are
murdered,
how many people die of cancer and how
many people.
There's a lot of statistics to follow
them.
You know when people are,
you know,
there has been over time,
you know that there's been a few people
that have been suicidal but like really,
really murdered,
but they would call it a recent ones
that were connected to Hillary Clinton
where people were like,
is that.
Explain that?
What is that two of them do?
Do you know the ones I'm talking about?
James,
this is,
this isn't about Haiti,
there's a Haiti thing going on.
There's a Haiti and is just a new one.
Yeah.
He was supposed to testify about the
money and the Clinton Foundation.
I mean that's what they said.
I don't know if he's officially gonna
testify about that,
but the city was going to at least talk
about it.
Yeah.
There was two dudes that died in the
same month during this 30 day period.
And they said they got suicided.
Yeah,
they both killed.
Killed themselves.
They both to testify.
So who knows?
Maybe they were really depressed and
maybe maybe.
Here you go.
Our former Haiti government officials
shoots himself in the head in Miami Area
Hotel.
My God.
Come on.
Yeah,
here and what,
what,
what was he doing?
He was getting ready to testify.
So was there another one?
Find another one.
There was another one that was really
recent.
It was in the same.
Was that July that you just looked down
the other one?
The other one was a girl.
It was a female.
Was it?
Yeah,
she was at part of the investigation.
Ends up suiciding herself like an
episode of the fucking house of cards.
Man,
isn't that crazy?
So obviously who knows,
maybe that were really depressed and
they wanted to shoot their brains out.
Maybe we don't know.
We don't know,
but I'm saying there's some fishy shit
going on there.
Right?
Here's the fish.
Here's the thing,
for sure.
Someone that works for the government
has had someone killed,
right?
For sure.
Let's just go.
Even Johnson was about to be indicted
for two murders before jfk got murdered,
but let's start from the beginning.
It was that true?
Yes.
I believe that.
Yeah.
And then let's start for somebody who
becomes president.
Boom.
It's gone.
Let's start from the beginning for sure.
Someone,
whether it was Nixon or whether it was
Theodore Roosevelt or Kennedy,
someone at some point in time wanted
someone dead.
Yeah.
And they did it and then pulled it off
and the best way to do it's called a
suicide.
Right?
And make it look not like a suicide
because then you're sending a message.
They do it on purpose.
Here's the question.
If we all agree and I think every
reasonable person would agree that
somewhere in government somewhere,
at some point in time someone has
ordered someone killed and got away with
it.
Right?
So that's what I'm saying.
Not so then the question is how many
other times?
Yeah.
How often did you find that chick who
recently got got a suicidal,
but hold on Eddie.
Here's the thing.
You've got to think of military strikes,
right?
If you're willing to authorize a
military strike,
you get to the point where you're
willing to say,
okay,
do it like especially a drone strike.
How about that?
Like this is the building,
the apartment building.
We're 97 percent sure he's in the
building.
Do we have the authorization like how
many civilians are dealing with
somewhere in the neighborhood of 30 to
100?
Okay.
Yeah,
my authorization and they do it and they
launched that.
Anytime you do that,
if you can do that,
if you can press that button and just
wipe out 100 people,
including the guy.
Anytime
you can do that.
Well,
you just killed 100 people that didn't
do anything wrong.
Now,
how easy is it going to be to kill some
people that you think do a little bit
wrong or annoying or keep fucking with
you or like,
you know,
the Michael Hastings story,
you know that story,
don't you?
Which ones that.
Michael Hastings,
did he get circumcised?
He was a journalist.
He commit suicide.
Michael Hastings was a journalist who
wrote for the rolling stone and he
followed around a general and he got
stuck over there.
There was something happened.
I think it was that volcano that went
off,
wasn't it?
Were they limited air travel for like a
month?
Anyway,
he got stuck over there while the
volcanoes,
they couldn't fly into this shit because
if the sky was hazy around this area,
um,
so he stuck around and they,
you know,
they got a little loose with them,
they joking around about stuff and he
was making jokes about Obama and the
rolling stone reported it and he wound
up getting retired.
He retired and stepped down.
He had to sort of step down because he
was in insane.
And after he did that,
like everybody was furious since this
report,
he got a shitload of death threats
because this guy was a serious general
and he really knew his shit and he was
well respected amongst its troops and he
had a step down and he had it put those
people in danger because this guy had an
inside track to these people and they
got a little comfortable around him and
they took this one part and put it in.
This article made this big story about
it.
Well,
he wound up driving his car into a tree
like 120 miles an hour.
I went and pulled that out of the car,
explode.
It's new cars,
new cars.
Apparently they can take over the car.
The car exploded and the engine was
launched from the vehicle,
like the engine blew up and was on the.
I forget how far away it was from the
car.
Fishy,
right?
Oh,
so crazy fishing.
But who knows?
They said this is what the thing they
said.
They said,
oh,
well he had amphetamines in his system.
Well,
you know why he had amphetamines in a
system?
Because he's a fucking writer.
Here's the dirty secret about writers.
They're all on adderall.
You guys a shit ton of.
I'm on adderall.
Like if someone's a writer and you've
got deadlines,
you've got to be like alert.
It's way too easy.
I have a good friend who told me that
almost all journalists and writers are
taking this stuff when they need it.
Is that helps,
right?
It helps.
It absolutely helps put.
So there's the crash and there's the
engine.
If fucking launched a block away and
they think that the conspiracy theory is
that they drove him,
not only drove him into a tree,
would they set a bomb in his car and
that it,
um,
it slammed in the bomb,
exploded in the engine launch.
Look how far away the engineers look at
the engine,
the upper right hand corner.
There's the car and they'll look at the
engine way up there.
It launched.
The whole thing is crazy.
So what my point was,
let me finish.
He fucked up his.
Even if the conspiracy theory that every
now and then
politician,
someone in power,
even maybe an entertainer has someone
suicided because they're in the elite,
they got all the connections and they
can get away with it.
Um,
even if that's not true,
and that's all bullshit.
And,
and every suicide generally as a
suicide,
even though it looks weird and then they
make it look like when you,
when you watched that movie that,
uh,
the documentary,
the Clinton chronicles on Youtube and
you watch that man,
man,
they,
they make it look obvious to send a
message like,
listen,
we got the corner in our pocket.
You don't want to fuck with us.
We can make anything happen and no one's
going to jail.
That's what that is.
But that's the conspiracy theory.
But if it's not a real,
damn,
that's a good idea.
You know what I mean?
Run with that shit.
That's a great idea.
If you're,
if you're corrupt and you want to hold
onto your power and you want to climb up
as high as you can in the political
world,
that's a great idea,
right on the corner.
Go after the corner,
whoever the,
wherever you're where you're a mayor,
what we go after the corner.
You got to own them and then there's
evidence that you look at stuff,
certain cases,
and it's obvious for certain cases they
fly in the corner,
they fly in.
It's,
it's so shady,
but why wouldn't it be and why wouldn't
you believe it will,
you know what do you want the best one
to Enron whistleblower who shot himself
in the head.
He shot himself in the head.
Exactly.
They do that on purpose.
That's an obvious one.
If you were a detective,
would you enter a case like that?
Go,
listen,
someone got suicided but it looks fishy.
Would you say,
Nah,
I'd suicide.
Don't disrespect the family.
Just keep it a suicide.
They told us it was.
No,
you would want to know what the fuck
really happened.
Like if one of like one of your
relatives died or whatever,
and they said she committed suicide and
you're like,
fuck.
But then someone you know that knows
him,
said it wasn't suicide brow it wouldn't
you want to know the details or would
you say it wasn't suicide?
That's what the COP said.
You know,
what we should have respect for their
soul and their family.
We just say that.
Or would you say,
tell me what the fuck happened.
What do you know?
Right,
right.
That's natural.
If it's her family fuck out.
So when it comes to stuff like,
um,
uh,
you look at Chris Cornell,
him and his wife had a foundation.
Him and Chester,
we're best friends.
The conspiracy theory,
I don't know if it's true,
but that we're gonna be found out some
shit.
They found out some shifts.
Let's be respectful.
No,
we don't.
We don't know.
I don't know.
I'm not naming any names,
but you got to look into it.
But it's.
This guy just died,
man.
I just don't think this is shit.
Do it on.
It's,
that's why you should speculate it when
you find out the connection and the way
they died it,
they made it.
Chris Cornell had nine broken ribs and a
gash in the back of his head and hung
them.
Yes,
and they said the official story is from
the CPR,
the CPR.
He was already dead when they got there
and they break nine ribs,
don't CPI,
and there's a gash behind his head
behind his head
when they cut them loose and he bangs
his head off the ground and he's
hanging.
He's hanging off a like one of those
exercise.
Someone killed him.
When?
When you look at the evidence,
you're like,
Holy Shit.
He looked like he was murdered.
And then chester right before chester
dies the same way,
the exact same way.
Let's not do this man.
I don't want to even do this.
Alright,
okay.
I'm just looking into.
Because I love Chester.
I love Chester.
I Love Lincoln Park,
Lincoln Park,
Lincoln Park.
I don't understand the theories involved
in this guy's death,
especially when he just died.
It just seems so disrespectful.
And I.
He was one of my favorite singers of all
time stand.
But if you really did just kill himself,
like it seems so disrespectful to
speculate that he was murdered because
of some conspiracy theory.
I don't know what the case is,
but I don't even want to talk about it.
But do you know what I'm saying?
That you know what I said enough.
I don't need to say no more.
I don't want to get into trouble,
but I'm just okay.
I'm not trying to put anybody in jail.
I'm just.
I Love Lincoln Park.
I love Chester.
I love Chris Cornell.
You can understand.
I understand.
I just feel like you should really know
what the fuck are you talking about when
you talk about people.
We were just talking about suicides.
We were just talking about.
We were just talking about is when you
look at what they were into,
they were into that.
They were into fighting that.
Okay.
And when you look at exactly how also
severely depressed,
there was also a lot of psychological
shit going on.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I don't know why people kill themselves,
period,
you know?
I don't know why,
but wouldn't you want to do serious?
There was some fish.
Maybe I'll look into it.
Talk about it until whatever the fuck
reality has been that we were talking
about.
We're talking about all these crazy
suicides.
We're talking about our that and then
this is insane.
This is time.
This is when you should bring it up.
Have not later when everyone forgets
about know any facts,
so when you're bringing it.
I'm just telling you.
Sounds crazy.
Okay.
Alright.
I get it.
He was probably.
He was.
He probably did it himself.
He could have very well easily have done
it himself and the whole thing is just
connecting them to some conspiracy
without like a d because I care about it
because I care about a deep
understanding of the.
I care about.
I care about them.
You don't know how,
how much,
how deep.
My understanding is.
I believe you.
Dude.
You don't know how deep my understanding
is.
You have to assume that just make this
happened.
No,
but I've looked into it.
What I assume you don't know who was
trying to kill them.
I assume you weren't there.
I assume that you don't know it as a
fact.
I was.
Trust me that I looked into it and you
wear the shoe you have,
man.
I sure you have.
I just,
it just me personally,
I feel very sensitive about that stuff.
I get.
No,
I get it.
I totally get it.
Let's change the subject.
Let's get into the UFC.
Okay.
Damien Maia,
can we turn the tie?
Rod Woodley,
Tyron,
tyron tie rod,
tyron Woodley.
Yeah.
That
people thought that was a boring match,
but for me there were tremendous data in
mma.
The fact like Damon goes down to one 70,
one 70 takes everybody down.
He's taking college wrestlers down left
and right,
but could he take down tyronn?
I thought I probably.
I thought that was that he was gonna hit
a wall there and he did.
How are you going to take that?
Do down.
It's going to be very,
very hard to take him down,
so we learned.
What I learned from that is,
man,
you got to get really good at shooting
and doing what Paul was an expert.
Paul says,
is the best ever I've ever seen an MMA
at making,
pulling guard option one,
you just made it like not option three.
I was talking about the third option.
I would want my fighter to have the best
standup possible,
the best takedowns possible.
Get on top,
grounded pound and submit them.
Beat them on the feet of your beat,
on beating them,
but if you're getting beat on the feet
and you can't take the guy down,
you better know how to pull guard you
gotta.
You gotta know how to drag dudes down,
unorthodox ways,
not just the regular wrestling.
Why?
Because you're going to hit tie Rod
Woodley,
you gotta throw some flying in an artist
on him.
You got to shoot deep enough just to get
a slight clench and have something
you're going to jump on.
Not with you,
not continue with the traditional
wrestling.
You gotta shoot pool,
half guard,
just like Andre Galvao did he when he
fought mma a few times,
that's all he did is shoot.
Dude,
sprawled.
You just pulled half guard below me.
Got Up double under hooks,
got the bag.
You got to get creative the way Nogueira
be 10 Sylvia,
way back in the day.
Ten Sylvia could not get taken down.
It's too tall,
Yada awesome.
Reach.
Nogueira was getting clipped.
It couldn't take down.
Tim.
Sylvia,
what did he do?
He shot the best he could.
And when Tim Silvia countered,
he pulled half guard.
He ended up in,
in,
uh,
in Deepak and boom with the momentum,
got up,
swept him.
So it was an indirect,
unorthodox take is what happened.
If you shoot pool guard and then sweep,
that's the take down.
You end up in the same place.
So he went around the,
the,
the wall,
and he ended up guillotine him put a
guillotine from the top.
You got to have that.
You got to.
And you know when he was pulling guard
before Damien,
Maia did pull guard before,
early in his career and he just wasn't
having it and he didn't.
That wasn't an option.
Tyrons takedown defense.
That was,
that was the take down defense.
Yes.
That was the last option.
But this is not,
I'm not talking about traditional
takedowns.
I'm talking about the art of watch Paul
Sas.
He would totally,
there's a time you can't just sit on
your butt and I think after talking to
take with a guy like tyron woodley is,
you're going to have to get a wrestler
who's like an elite high caliber
wrestler that's going to be able to
figure out how to take him down.
I don't think like a regular dude like
Damien Maia who's not a regular dudes,
a world class grappler,
but just here.
Dominick Cruz is criticism of his,
uh,
his takedown temps that he wasn't
following through enough and what he was
saying technically was wrong.
Yeah.
You know,
I think that if it was a real world
class grappler for a real,
you know,
top of the
food chain,
amateur wrestling had one taken
everybody down.
He is like the best wrestler.
What he said about the fence,
because most of Damien Maia take downs,
a lot of them anyways are against the
fence.
He's really good at going double under
hooks and doing some inside trips or
outside trips.
Tyron,
defendant,
all that shit.
But you know,
what else tyron did?
He clipped him with a huge uppercut and
the very first exchange,
the very first time Damien tried to
close the distance,
tyron hit him with a vicious uppercut
and he fucked his left eye up.
Damien's left.
I was fucked up from the very first
exchange,
the Damien shot low tire and hit him
with a heart uppercut and just as his,
I immediately swell up and it was fucked
for the rest of the fight.
So I think that that played a factor
too.
Just tyrons game plan was in a lot of
people's eyes,
wasn't fun to watch.
That was the problem and like Dana felt
like he should have finished them.
And tyron his thought was,
look,
this is this guy's.
It's his goal is to win the title.
You've got to come and try to beat me.
And when the title,
if I'm beating you,
why?
Why don't I just keep doing what I'm
doing and continue winning the fight.
You can't do anything,
but if I changed tactics and make myself
more vulnerable.
And he said he did get hit by a lefthand
or a couple left hands and that the
stunned them.
I guess his attitude was,
look,
if this guy wants to win that title,
he's gotTa come and get it and it
becomes get it.
I'm going to knock him the fuck out and
if he doesn't come and get it,
why would I?
Why would I go after him and put myself
out of position?
I would coach Woodley the exact same
lane.
I would be yelling from the corner.
Just keep doing what you're doing.
Don't one fucked up exchange,
gets a shot in and take some trips.
Him.
He tries to get up on his knees,
jumps on his back,
and that little scramble.
One little scramble like that.
Boom,
you just fucked your whole shit up.
Damien is not the best punch her in the
world,
but he's not the worst either.
He can fuck you up if you.
If you make a mistake and if you rush in
and maybe he's reserved more energy than
you think he has and he fires a very
fast rate lefthand and catches you on
the chin.
He could fuck you up.
He can fuck anybody up.
He's not incompetent on the feet.
He's just not at the same level as
tyron.
He doesn't have the same movement.
It's tire.
Do you think Damien should would have.
Damien had kicks a more like maybe not
exactly like,
but more in the vein of Edson Barboza
Rodriguez.
Wouldn't that be a whole nother
dimension?
Blake doesn't even have to be like that.
How about just like Pedro his Oh,
just attack the legs.
Just make,
make the legs.
He's not doing that right now.
Very little boxing.
Well,
dominick brought it up one time during
the broadcast because he's like,
I want to see Damien throw high kick,
a left high kick.
I go,
yeah,
but I go,
have you ever seen Damian throw a left
high kick?
And he's like,
I don't know.
I'm like,
I don't know either.
I don't know if he's ever done it.
I'm not,
I'm not disagreeing with you,
but I'm saying I don't think I've ever
seen him try it.
Like he doesn't.
I think he's such a specialist and his
specialty is just get you to the ground
strangling.
He should spend grounds.
I would suggest.
I don't know.
I ain't shit,
but I would like to see Damien Maia with
some with a adding to his arsenal,
adding kicks,
adding more whiteboards like why not for
sure,
but even if he did,
the problem is it's like tyron is just
so fucking strong and so good at stuff
and takedowns any hits,
so God damn hard.
It's like you'd have to be like on him
and you got to figure out how to
actually get him to the ground,
have full control of him and good luck
with all that.
Remember Nogueira versus Mark Coleman?
Yeah.
That that Mark Coleman was planning on
going to the ground with a Nogueira at
all.
This was at the height of pride.
Mark Coleman's plan was to box with him,
use his wrestling to not go to the
ground.
That was the plan the whole way through.
I'm going to box this Nogueira guy.
He's got an amazing guard,
amazing Jujitsu,
and he ain't going to take me down.
I fucking wrestled the Columbus.
What happened?
Didn't know Garrett.
Take them down.
Fuck no,
he didn't know what he did.
He's like,
people who can throw high kicks in,
a lot of head kicks usually don't
because they're afraid of going to the
ground.
All the guys that could do that,
but guys that want to be on the ground
and don't mind being on their back and
are dangerous off the back and are known
for having a dangerous guard like
Nogueira.
They could throw all the high kicks they
want and that's exactly what know Kara
did.
He started throwing high kicks whizzing
by,
Mr Coleman's had and then one just
barely nipped his forehead.
So Mark Coleman just snapped into
wrestling,
said,
fuck these baseball bats.
I'm going to ground and pound this
motherfucker.
Take my chances in his garden.
He took him down.
He got triangle.
Yeah.
That was the glory days of Jujitsu.
Heavyweight champion.
It was a triangle arm bar.
And that you were out to exactly how I
felt back then.
Yeah,
that's how we got to fight to the
ground.
It's by throwing head kicks and scaring
the motherfucker wrestling.
You know,
cowboy.
He used to do that a lot.
Cowboy has a nasty guard and one of the
reasons why guard is,
I mean one of the reasons why so loose
with his kicks,
because he doesn't mind if you take them
down,
if you take them down,
he tie shit up quick.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's what they need.
Mondelez throw his head kicks head kicks
all the time because he hits guard is
super dangerous.
His gardens to jump in his garden,
there's like 40 slash 50 percent chance
you're going to tap.
Yeah.
His gardens saying yeah,
he just a.
He did an Ebi maybe like eight months
ago.
He pulled off some beautiful rubber
guard man.
He looked like a fucking Ninja.
Yeah,
he's a bad motherfucker and he's a bad
motherfucker.
He's got a crazy athletic frame too,
you know,
he's like,
he's.
He's built like this gigantic superhero
type character.
He's a cute dude.
Built like a big small dude and he's all
handsome and shit.
He's right up there with Alan jobe.
Beautiful Man.
He's right there.
I would put them right there,
but don't you think like when you look
at his proportions and the way he moves,
he's almost like a,
you know,
a lot of big guys.
Like they look like big guys.
You know what I'm saying?
Like a,
like a perfect example would be like
that.
Do that just submitted Travis Browne.
Was it only neck?
Is that how you say it?
The guy that got that done just
submitted.
Travis Brockie.
No,
choke off his bass off his back.
That guy,
he just be transparent.
Did He,
what?
Did he get them in arm?
Trying to get them in like a rear naked
choke on the side.
Oh,
that's right.
He does crazy.
His squeeze must be insane.
Oh,
he's probably just known in this gym is
like did he's going to help get a hold
of your neck and just smash it to.
He's a,
he's a spooky good grappler.
You'd see like when he gets a hold of
guys that he's putting like a crusher
squeeze on for the people don't
understand what he did.
He let a guy mount him and he choked the
guy while the guy was on top of them.
That is insane and unheard of.
He was mounted who was mounted,
which means it's one of the worst
positions you could ever be in an mma.
The guys on top of you,
he's his hips are above your hips.
He's pinning you to the ground and this
guy choked the guy from the bottom.
It never happens.
The fact that he could do it,
I mean,
here we can see it here.
What,
what,
how do you spell,
how do you say his name is?
Wassily.
Alexi.
Alexi,
Alexi Olynyk.
So he's just ragdoll and travis here and
he gets his back and look at this.
He's got a rear naked on the side with a
body scissors.
Look how he's squeezing the body and
just smush them so he can't breathe.
He's got them in a locked down.
Across the body.
Yeah.
And then he gets the neck and he's under
inac.
Just sort of like a sideways rear naked
choke.
The other one he did is even crazier
when you see him submit.
The guy from the bottom with a mesial
choke.
See that kind of guy that looks like a
big guy.
You know what it looks like?
A big guy.
Vinny Magallanes looks like a
welterweight.
That's six foot three for some strange
reason.
Two hundred and 30 pounds.
Is He fighting MMA anymore?
They just going to do Jujitsu.
I'm not sure.
He's going to come back and do the
absolute Ebi absolutes going to be a at
on it.
This shit.
Look at this shit.
This is crazy.
Who fucked does that?
Watch them do that again.
That's ever done that back that up
again.
People are going to try it now.
So going all the way to the beginning so
the guy gets mount and he.
He thinks he's got to go.
I got them out here and he just sinks
this in and look how tidy makes this
choke into the.
Into the throat.
We're crazy,
dude.
That seems legit.
Fuck yeah,
it's legit.
It's 100 percent legit,
I think.
I think that's super legit.
Yeah.
If you look at the way the arms are
folding up here,
I mean,
that's not a goon,
right?
That's a front naked truck yet is that
is.
Um,
it's all like real leverage.
You know,
how you could tell if a guy goon
somebody just crushing their head.
That's not a good squeeze right there.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's fitting in like a like keys,
right?
Yeah.
It's fitting in there perfectly.
Your squeeze has to be super high level
to get it to choke someone while being
mounted.
Oh good Lord.
Good Lord.
How many people have that?
See,
this tyron woodley thing is very tricky
because in my mind,
like I see that he wanted to win the
fight period.
That is the best way to win the fight.
If this guy is only offering a certain
amount of offense and you could stuff
that offense and land your shots and
continue to pile up points,
which he did and don't ever put yourself
at risk.
I get it.
But I also get the Dana white point of
view where he's like,
you got to sell tickets.
Like people are paying to see you fight.
And if people are holding up cell phones
and swinging them through the rafters,
you know,
because everybody's bored because they
don't want to watch it anymore.
And his,
his thought is like,
you got to sell tickets.
Hey,
who's the greatest take down artists in
UFC history?
George St Pierre to her same po versus
Woodley.
Yeah,
but Woodley apparently because of this
fight,
they're talking about GSP versus
bisping.
Oh,
they got to go to woodland.
Come on.
That's the only guy.
If GSP just take woodley down,
nobody can.
But what if they just tried to take each
other down,
back and forth and everybody went crazy
again.
Took him down repeatedly.
If he didn't like he would,
that'd be great too.
But what if he did?
Either way,
I want to see the fight because.
Because,
because Woodley has a style.
Some people don't like it,
some people like it,
some people appreciate it or whatever.
But the only guy that has a shot to beat
Woodley,
the only guy would be the best takedown,
best mma takedown artists of all time.
He has like a million takedowns in the
UFC.
He's the only guy that would be able to.
If GSP can do it,
no one can.
He's also very good striker.
I think kicks.
This is what you'd have GSP saying.
You got to go to the pro wrestling
angle.
You know,
I am tired of sitting at home watching
boring fights as bad gsp impression on
him saying like,
enough already.
I want my sound.
It sound like Arnold.
Kenny made ivs.
Um,
I don't know.
Bisping's at one 95.
That's kind of weird.
Is he saying,
man,
it's going to be too hard to make one 70
without the ivs.
I think he was willing to fight either
fight.
I think he was willing to do one 70 or
one add woodley.
GSP would be huge.
That would.
That would be the biggest fight for.
I'm not impressed with because who else
is there at one 70 that has a chance of
taking him down.
Well,
Robbie lawler,
since he just won,
you would have to look at Robbie's
contenders,
so he would just brawl with him.
He's willing to brawl with them if you
can avoid the big bomb,
but he got hit with in the first fight,
you know,
and you gotta think Robbie lawler is
coming off of five round war with Rory
Macdonald,
five round war with Carlos Condit,
war with Johny Hendricks war war,
war,
war.
It's all war.
Every fight.
He's in his war.
So like I think the him having a year
off was giant and then he fought cowboy
and towards the end he was coming after
cowboy.
He was hurting cowboy to the body.
He hit Cabo with some big shots.
I felt like a lot of people disagree
with that decision,
but I felt like I give Robbie the first
round because he jumped all over cowboy
in the beginning it was,
I think it was enough to win the round,
although I think Cabo is getting the
better of the exchanges,
the NFL silting the volume of and,
and the impact when to Robbie second
round when to cowboy.
Pretty big.
But then Robbie rallied and the third
round and I think he dominated the third
round and I think you hurt cowboy a few
times.
I think that would have been an amazing
five round fight.
That would have been an incredible.
Remember who won the fight?
Robbie?
One very close decision.
I think it was a split decision.
I don't know.
My grade five bring a scrambled.
It was a great fight.
Both gave.
Both took.
It was,
it was war.
It was chaos,
you know,
and in cowboy definitely caught them
with some clean shots.
He hit him some real good.
Nice.
The body as well.
Cowboy landed a lot of great shit.
But you know,
Robbie looked like Robbie again.
He looked like the Robbie lawler that
won the title.
It looks like a killer.
He looked like the same spooky dude that
just keeps coming after you until he
puts you away.
That's what he looked like in the third
round.
Third round,
particular really looked like he was
falling back into the old groove again.
So there's him.
You know,
man,
it's crazy.
Seeing Rory Macdonald over in beltour
looking better than ever,
looking better than ever.
When he took down Paul daily,
like he,
he cracked Paul on the feet,
didn't get hit with shit.
Took Paul down and strangled the shit
out of him.
And the way he did it,
you watch it,
you go,
whoa.
Like Rory Macdonald might be the best
welterweight on the planet.
Like he might,
he might write,
be there,
you know,
you've got to remember he beat Tyron
Woodley.
Remember that fight?
I don't remember.
Roy.
Shut him down.
Shut down that big overhand right
compressed against the cage.
Not that long ago.
Maybe if I had a gas.
Two Thousand 15.
I think he fought tyron woodley before
he fought Robbie lawler.
I think it was one of those elimination
was that was a decision.
Yeah,
it'd be really by decision and the also
be Damien Maia and he survived being
mounted by Damien mine in the first
round.
Damien took him down mouth to them.
He defended and then he fucked Damien up
and the second and third rounds and he's
still peaking duties like 26.
He's one of the best in the world.
Without a doubt.
He might be the best without a doubt.
Yeah.
It bums me out seeing him over at Bella
Tor.
I think that kid is sensational.
Is Kelvin coming back down to one 70?
What do you think?
I think he can make it for sure.
I think if Calvin had the kind of
discipline that Chris Weidman has to get
down to 85.
Chris Weidman's a huge guy.
He has to have real discipline to make
that 185 pound limit.
I mean he has to really watch his
calories because you walk around it.
I would like to know it's well north of
200 pounds,
so he's a big guy,
you know,
according to Ray Longo,
Matt Serra that like Chris is on the big
side of 85,
like he could easily be on the small
side of 205,
you know?
And then do you,
what do you think about these new weight
class?
It was like the athletic commissions.
Now they're,
they're going to add 65,
75,
95 and I think to 20 to 25 to the UFC
going to do this.
I don't know if the use is going to do
it,
but I think they should.
I think they should go every 10 pounds.
Not every five pounds,
but every 10 pounds like it the way it
is.
Do you feel like it just.
It makes sense every.
It makes sense,
but they don't need to or something.
I don't think we need it.
It makes sense.
I don't mind the big jumps really find
your spot.
We don't need more.
It'll just be.
It'll just.
I don't know.
At this point,
I think you keep it the way it is,
but who knows what they're going to do?
I don't agree.
I think we need more weight classes.
I think there's two big jumps.
I think the jump of like one 85 to two.
Oh five.
It's fucking crazy.
As a 20 pound jump.
That's huge.
The difference between a guy who's 85
and the guy was two,
oh,
five is significant.
The amount of power that guy has over
the 85 pounders.
Fucking huge.
Trying to spot 55.
It's too many.
There's too many tweeners like Diego
Sanchez.
Diego Sanchez is probably a 65 or you
know,
maybe a little too small for 70.
Maybe too big for 55.
I think there's a few of those guys.
He's gotten down to 45.
I know.
Not good though.
I mean not.
Not fought like to Diego Sanchez of old.
I don't know.
I think it should sustain them.
It's 55 is spot.
Yeah.
I think it's hard for him to even make
that though.
If you could let them fight at 65,
he'd have all his energy.
It makes sense what you're saying.
Like get.
It totally makes sense.
But the fighting,
it's just fighting,
you know,
let's not diluted we got enough.
We need more.
We don't have everything.
Doesn't have to be like just all
systematically.
Fair.
You know,
just think that's the case.
I don't think we have enough.
I think we get a room for more
champions.
I think we'd have more super fights.
We'd have more guys rise to the top of
the division and it will be easier to
match them up.
It's way easier to match up a 75 with an
85 than it is to match up a 70 with an
85 or 55 with an 85.
It's just like the gaps are too big.
I think we have too much already.
I think it's hard to keep track of shit
the way it is.
Maybe there's an argument for that,
I guess.
I don't know.
I like it though.
I think it gives people more options.
I think heavyweights,
for sure.
It gives them more options.
I would also like to see a super
heavyweight division.
I would like to see a full on freak
show.
I want to see the mountain from game of
thrones.
I want to see that guy learn how to
fight.
He's like 330 fucking pounds.
You know that guy that picks up those
stone balls and shit.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Carries cars.
He's one of those dudes.
How big is he,
John?
Yeah.
How tall is he?
Six.
Eight.
Something like that.
Yeah.
Viking,
straight viking long hair.
Beard.
No.
He's got a beard.
He's like one of those Iceland guys,
I think Sweden or Iceland.
One of them.
One of them Viking characters.
How big is that mountain dude?
There's a video of him sparring with
conor Mcgregor.
It's hilarious.
He's six foot nine.
Jesus Christ.
What in the fuck is that?
Is there a picture of him?
Jesus Christ,
he weighs 300.
Eighty pounds.
Three hundred 86 with him picking up
cars.
Oh yeah,
there's,
there's a bunch of videos of him doing
shit here.
Watch him.
That's him.
See if they have some videos of him
doing his workouts.
His workouts are fucking insane or in in
some sort of strong man competition.
Do you ever see.
Go back.
Go back to the screen you just had.
See,
scroll down to that conor mcgregor
video.
The screen you just had.
That's it right there.
See conor mcgregor versus the mountain
and cottage playing around with them.
Sparring with a look at the size of this
guy and counties like slapping him in
the stomach.
He's like,
come on,
I'm going to grab you think he's trying
to grab him.
Oh,
look at this.
He's like,
come on man.
High Five.
Yeah,
he's getting tired.
He's getting tired.
Damn.
Kind of wanted to keep going.
He's pulling him in the stomach.
Got a mad mad.
This is real now.
Yeah.
It's getting real.
How old is this?
It's pretty recent.
Like before he fought Aldo.
Damn.
Look at this guy.
He's just kidding.
I do with straight left face.
He's mad.
Dude.
This is why conor mcgregor is such a bad
motherfucker.
He's so.
He's so crazy.
Like legitimately crazy.
They just like Bruce Lee.
He's just popping that guy in the
stomach with those straight left and you
don't like it and he knows that dude's
getting tired.
He threw his kicks dude.
Like he's pinning his leg together
inside his crotch and just getting them
to old.
Just pick up connor if you wanted to
jump in front.
Kicked him in the body.
Oh Shit.
He's just teeing off on him.
I need to move.
And the dude's got hired.
He's so big a side kick him right now.
It just keeps popping and with that
straight left,
look at that.
This is crazy because this goes for a
few minutes back and guarantee that dude
is not doing a whole lot.
He's getting tired,
man.
Look at him.
He's backing up.
Big giant.
Six foot.
What?
What does a six,
nine,
six,
three,
86.
He's getting tired.
He's trying to grab them.
Nope.
Nope,
not today,
sir.
He's laughing.
His father said.
He's like,
dude,
he was like a Bruce Lee laugh.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is real.
So you look at it over and over again.
It keep popping them with that straight
left.
It's funny,
man.
It's weird to watch,
right?
He tried to give him a high five to
stop.
His daughter said,
ah,
yeah.
Okay.
No.
Oh,
tagged him.
He's throwing.
Yeah.
This is not into that.
Nothing to that.
Oh Dude.
Yeah.
He doesn't get that.
He doesn't like it.
Those are hard shots
he gave up.
Oh Wow.
That was basically a real fight.
That was a half a real fight.
That was like a half a real fight.
Right.
That looked like a real fight to me.
Didn't they?
Didn't punch to the face.
I don't think he wanted a punch to the
face.
It would have been a bad move.
Yeah.
Just stick to the body.
You can't even reach his face.
Yeah.
You're not going to hit that face.
Look at what he does.
He throws a Kettlebell over the top of
the fucking do.
What if it landed on his head?
Um,
you gotta watch the,
a youtube channel or the weather?
The instagram page.
Is it instagram?
No.
Twitter.
Jesus Christ.
Twitter page.
Hold my beer.
Have you ever seen the twitter page?
No.
Maybe Jude.
It's.
Is it perhaps the greatest twitter page
that's ever existed and it's hold my
beer while I do this and they do some
stupid shit over and over again.
What does this hold my beer while I.
Oh,
that's a good one.
He opened up a beer with a,
a football,
but that's not.
Scroll down a little bit.
Let me show you my,
some ridiculous ones.
You find the right one.
There's a ton of videos of one guy did a
back flip.
He tried to do a back flip off the top
of these bricks.
Oh,
don't do this one.
That one's horrible.
Guys going to karate kick that girl in
the head.
I get this.
Oh,
be or why kicked this can off your head.
Watch this guy hold my beer while I sit
on an airbag.
Watches.
What does the hold my beer?
Did they say that?
No,
no,
no they don't.
But um,
what's this one is you got light and the
guy on fire.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
The fuck is he doing?
Oh,
it's basically hold my beer while I
fucking ridiculous Easter.
Oh,
we blew up.
Oh Shit.
Okay,
scroll down.
Scroll down.
Not that one.
Keep going.
That one right there.
This guy's pretty bad ass like that.
He actually made it.
Sometimes they may.
Yeah,
but watch this one.
It's good.
Oh Shit.
I guess try to do a back flip off a
stack of bricks or something.
Okay,
that's enough.
That's enough.
But if anybody's interested,
go to hold my beer on,
on twitter.
It's fucking late.
I try to retweet them at least like once
a month.
He's fine.
The most ridiculous shit.
Who's instagram accounts?
Oh yeah.
Do you find fun?
I think,
uh,
the beastmaster oh,
you mean Derek Lewis?
Derrick Lewis.
The funny.
He's hilarious.
Follow him.
Follow his instagram might be the best
instagram I follow.
Do you see the one where the dudes were
trying to jump out of the way of some
rolling.
Hey,
they got a bale of hay rolling down this
hill and they do try to jump out of the
way and got fucking launched into the
air heats.
I mean,
he's the most gangster shit talkers in
the UFC.
I mean,
he was more gangster than him.
He's more gangster than Tito did.
Mike Tyson,
you know what I mean?
Mike Tyson
said crazy shit.
He said,
uh,
I'll eat your children eight the
gentleman.
And he said,
um,
I'll fuck you to you love me.
But he said that before the fight,
you know,
you after the fight.
He's not saying that.
You know what I mean?
He's not know when Derrick Lewis,
when he called out Rhonda,
that was fucked up.
That's a low blow.
That was a low blow.
No one's done that.
No one,
even Roberto Duran called that said
something about a sugar ray Leonard's
wife,
but that was before the fight.
Afterwards they become.
They became friends and then they became
friends.
I think it was after the second fight
that became friends.
Yeah.
I have the first fight he tried to hold.
That was like one of the famous to watch
some movie there.
Roberto Duran pushed him away.
No,
I never saw it,
but after the end of the first fight,
he tried to like embrace Duran Duran.
Pushed him well and he's still wanting
to fight.
It's pretty crazy.
It's a crazy ending of the fight.
See if you can pull up the video.
The very last moments of the round with
the first time Roberto Duran fought
sugar ray Leonard.
He beat him and he knew at the end that
he beat him and so when the bell rang,
you just fucking dropped his glove and
he's like staring him down like he's
still ready to go.
It's crazy.
Roberto Duran was a wild motherfucker
back.
You mentioned if after Michael Mike
Tyson knocked out Michael spinks.
Then when they get in the post binding
or interview,
he said,
I'll eat his children.
I can't imagine him saying that after
the fight people will go,
what the fuck ways.
We have Michael spinks children at
finance.
So this is,
uh,
the first fight.
At the very end seconds he goes to shake
his hand.
He's like,
fuck you.
So he comes near.
I'm looking at this,
what the Fuck Outta here?
He pushes them away.
Fuck,
that was after the first fight.
After the fight was over,
he pushed him.
Riley's fucking screaming at him.
He's like,
fuck you.
Yeah.
And when did he say that thing to sugar
ray's wife before for this fight?
For this?
Yeah,
that's right.
He got into Ted.
Did that to get in his head.
Oh,
well he was just that guy to the.
Apparently there was a,
there was an article written where they
went to visit him and Panama and uh,
he took a cat and he picked it up by the
tail and smashed against a wall.
And they were like,
well,
according to the movie it was a.
He had moments where he got out of
control,
but generally it was a very good guy in
the movie.
Two movies are weird.
I don't know if they're true,
but apparently he did that too.
I've read the story.
I don't,
I don't know what the story might be
bullshit,
but I'm like,
if he was that crazy,
you know,
living on the streets in Panama,
like becoming a savage boxer.
He was so good too,
man.
He was ferocious.
And when he beat up Davey Moore and
Dave,
you remember that David Morris was
thought to be the guy,
like in everybody thought after no moss.
Roberto Duran was done.
So they had this kid stud boxer,
David,
more world champion at 1:54,
I believe.
That was after no months.
Yeah,
there was the comeback fight.
Roberto Duran,
when he was really fully back,
he boxed up.
David Morgan stopped him,
was a tremendous upset because David
Moore was a lot bigger than them to
white guy.
No,
David was black guy.
David wound up getting killed,
uh,
working on a car fucked
up.
He was trying to fix his car and he
fucked up with the Jack and it crushed
them.
They could be conspiracy,
yes or no and look into it.
Oh Man.
So,
um,
you saw the UFC this weekend.
Do you see where I fucked up and I,
I interviewed Daniel cormay after he had
been knocked out.
Here's,
here's something that's like,
people think that somehow or another,
a doc told me not to do that.
And I did it.
Nobody said anything.
It was just a 100 percent my fuck up.
And it was also my idea in the first
place to stop interviewing fighters
after they'd been knocked out.
It was 100 percent my idea.
And how often did it happen before in
championship fights?
It happened often,
right?
Almost always.
Whether a guy got knocked out or Tko or
submitted or last decision,
I would interview the winter and I would
interview the loser every time,
every time,
unless they ran out of the cage,
which has happened before.
I get it.
So you're just on running on instincts
and this is what happened.
Um,
I was there for Gonzaga versus cro cop.
Remember Gonzaga head kick,
Cro,
cop,
and just fucking into oblivion and it
was bad and I interviewed Cro Cop
afterwards and I'm telling you,
that dude had no idea what I was talking
about.
Yeah.
And I remember saying to the,
to the production team at the time,
it was like,
man,
I don't think we should interview guys
after they get knocked out like that.
That was my nice my saying like that.
And then I'm.
The one time it happened again,
it was with allister and after when
Alistair overeem fuss deep,
a mule chick and he remembered this
gating that didn't really happen.
You remembered a steep,
a tapping rather.
And it didn't really happen.
I was like,
this poor guy,
like he's,
he really has this memory in his head
and it's just not correct because he
just got knocked the fuck out.
He got knocked unconscious on
television,
like completely flat line and then a few
minutes later I'm asking him to be
coherent.
I'm like,
I don't think it's fair.
So it was my idea to stop doing this and
the UFC agreed.
So it's not like,
like they said,
we got to stop doing it and I viol
violated my own idea and I just did it
on.
This is what happened after the fight
was over.
First of all,
the fight was crazy.
Shocking how violent the ending was
because John Really did fucking hate
Daniel and Daniel I think really did
hate John or at least had real anger.
There was real emotions with these guys.
It was insane.
It was intense.
When John landed that fucking head kick
and you saw him moving in for the kill
and then he,
he stopped them right in front of us.
He got on top of him and just blasted
him.
It was like right there.
I remember looking over and I'm like,
Jesus,
he was just dropping del close real
close to.
It was pretty close,
if I remember correctly.
I want to say it was like right off to
my right.
If I remember correctly.
You had a good look at it.
I had a real good look at it.
Yeah,
I mean obviously I'm cage side.
I got a good look at everything,
but I had a real good look at that.
It intense.
It was intense and it was also.
I felt like there was a couple of shots,
too many,
so I remember being stunned like,
oh,
I'm a.
I'm a big fan of John Jones,
but I'm also a big fan of Daniel and I'm
a fan of both of them.
I know they don't like each other,
but I like both of them.
I liked them independently.
It just,
I can't help the fact their enemies,
but I love hanging out with John and I
love hanging out with Danny.
I love doing commentary with Daniel.
I love that guy.
So I would never do anything to make him
look bad.
I just got.
I was in shock.
There was.
He was confused because he got knocked
out so he was confused that why the
fight was stopped and said he was mad
that they stopped the fight because he
just didn't understand because he just
been chaos.
So he was arguing with big John.
I didn't hear the exact words.
Then he was arguing with Dana.
I didn't hear the exact words that
either,
but Dana was in front of me.
It's you got to realize when a Kao like
that happens in a world championship
fight and you're standing in the
octagon,
you're surrounded by all these people
screaming and cheering.
The fucking noise is so loud.
It's hard to figure out what the fuck is
happening.
So I couldn't figure out what Daniel and
Dana were arguing about,
but Dane,
his whole head was red.
He was like,
he was like,
that fight was amazing.
He fought your heart out.
Like I couldn't tell exactly what he
said,
like you'd hold your head up high.
It was a great fight,
that kind of stuff,
but I think Daniel was still trying to
figure out why the fight was stopped
because it just had happened.
He'd just woken up.
Then he realized he got head kicked and
then he was really sad and then he was
upset and I went to go talk to him and
literally as I'm going to talk to him,
he's turning to me and I have the
microphone.
I'm like,
why am I interviewing him?
After he got knocked out,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
Like I don't even realize what I was
doing.
I was just in shock almost like I went
on instinct and I'm interviewing him.
If I had a chance to stop and think I
should have been like,
oh yeah,
he's been Kao don't do it.
So in the middle of me even talking to
him,
I say I normally,
I don't like to interview fighters after
they've been knocked out,
but it's just like I was stuck.
I was already there talking to him and I
didn't want to leave and walk away from
them and I really do care about that guy
a great deal.
And I just watched him get knocked out.
Now watch him.
His heart's pouring out and he's crying,
you know,
when he was realizing that he got
knocked out and he lost the fight.
It was all awful.
And um,
so I put it a Po.
It was haunting me all night.
This is,
nobody had said anything.
Nobody from the UFC got mad at me.
No one said anything to me.
There was just me thinking,
why did I do that?
Like,
why did I interview him?
I shouldn't have interviewed him even
though we used to do it for every fight.
Um,
it was the right move to stop doing it.
And ironically it was my idea.
It was my move.
I don't even know if other guy.
I don't know if Brian standstill
interviews guys after they've been
knocked out.
I don't think he does though,
because Brian Actually said thank you to
me for that because he got interviewed
after he got knocked out by vandelay and
he remembers thinking,
I don't remember what happened.
He didn't know what the fuck and they're
interviewing him.
He's trying to keep it together for the
interview.
And he was like,
you're right.
It's not fair.
It's not fair to interview a fighter
after they've been knocked out.
I just fucked up man.
There's no other way to say it.
I just,
uh,
I,
if I could go back,
I definitely would have taken it back.
I definitely wouldn't have interviewed
him because I feel,
I feel like he didn't.
And he sent me a text message saying
it's all good.
I didn't say anything crazy,
so it's no big deal.
But you know,
he could have,
you know,
he could have said I never got stopped.
I could have said,
you know,
he could,
you don't think anything.
Like if somebody doesn't explain to him
well enough what happened?
And then it takes a few seconds and you
forget again.
That's the other thing about guys have
been knocked out.
Like you say,
if,
if I got knocked out and I asked you at
what happened and you said,
oh,
this dude just punched you in your jaw
and knocked you out.
And be like,
no way.
Hey Man.
What happened?
Like as a few seconds later,
you start asking again when you get
knocked out.
It's real weird.
So it's a huge fuck up on my part.
But it was,
I was in shock.
Honestly.
It was so ferocious.
The final barrage was so ferocious and
there was the way it was.
The Way John did it when you heard them,
once he knew he heard them,
he just started going after him.
And one of the spookiest things that he
did,
was he,
the way he tripped him,
see what he tripped him like Daniel's
like sort of stumbling back and John
just sorta scoops his leg out from under
him and Trypsin Daniel Falls back and
John just moves in on him and you could
tell Daniel just couldn't get his feet
back under them and John just jumped on
him and just marked them.
[inaudible] did great on his feet for
awhile there.
He did great.
But I was really impressed with John
John Stryker to.
He throws so much unorthodox.
She,
those stomps on the knees do.
That's high level shit.
And the volume.
Yes.
Throwing strikes.
Yeah.
That's his,
that's his shit.
He was in tremendous shape.
Stolen those uh,
those elbows from,
you know,
from left field,
right down the pipe.
Yeah.
He's done a lot of elbows,
man.
And he's throwing all kinds of shit.
He throws everything front kicks.
There was a lot of front kick right to
the.
Yeah.
Those fret snap kegs throws those
oblique kicks in.
Hyperextends your needed love that can't
get close to him.
I'd love that.
Whoa,
I hope it keeps going because he's
evolving so much as a striker.
I hope he.
I hope against hope it gets good to
gather 100 percent.
You never seen him arrested again.
No more bullshit.
No one cares about that.
I do.
Don't want them to get arrested again.
It's like he tore his acl.
What's the difference?
I believe that he's going to be back.
I know it doesn't matter.
Let them party.
He's the king of the world.
He's the.
He's the probably the best fighter of
all time.
Let them do some coke.
Let them party data should be getting
some house.
You know what I mean?
Fuck it.
He gets fucked up.
Hey,
that's actually better press.
So what he needs is like you should fake
Duis and drunk and stoned just like they
do.
And TMZ,
he just needs a constant security detail
to keep everything away from him.
Let him,
let him do whatever he wants.
He's the king of the fucking world.
You don't want them getting.
We'd lost a whole year of him and then
we lost a year before that.
I don't want him to get Tyson that
that's for sure.
He can get locked up for five years.
That shit happens.
A peanut.
You want what you want them to do is
have fun,
but don't do anything illegal.
Don't let him drive.
Take us.
Take his keys.
Still want to do anything illegal.
Saturday team.
Have a rubber party room locked up,
but just say,
dude,
you'd go off five hours,
whatever you want.
Boom,
but you can leave this room.
Do you ever been to one of them?
A bouncy warehouses?
We can go from one trampoline to the
next champion that all the time,
me and my son go the time.
Those are the best man.
Best.
So anyway,
even though I already talked to Daniel,
I felt like I put it on twitter.
I apologize on instagram and I was like,
I gotta apologize in the podcast too.
I fucked up and it was just a.
It was.
There was no other explanation.
Is it?
Is it because of the name of his crying
face?
No,
I'm just meeting just to talk to them.
That means you're going to have names,
man.
You got to accept me as part of the
other ones.
Come to mind.
There's so many.
Knock out means you have the Rashad
Evans one that's pretty pop.
It's one of the most of the Jose Aldo
one.
That's pretty good.
That's on the underground.
The underground.
Boom.
It's the Jose Aldo.
Get clipped by A.
There's so many of them.
Did you ever see the video of the dude
that came up to Rashad and asked him to
sign one of the posters of a shot?
All fucked up where we say that again?
Some dude had the balls to come up to
Rashad at,
uh,
one of those signings and try to get
Rashad to sign the picture.
The one picture.
Where is all Jack?
And try to get them to sign that.
Rashad crumpled it up.
Him Up.
He thought he was being cute.
What's this?
That's the dude.
He walks up to him.
He says,
get the fuck out of here man.
Oh Shit.
Damn.
He's like,
no,
get out of here.
Go.
You want to hear it?
So hold on.
Oh,
that,
rewind it.
So it will go before that.
When you see him rip it up.
Mexicans here dammit.
Mexicans hands in the picture.
Crumples it up and throws it at me.
He's laughing and he pushes him and like
get out of here man.
He's laughing.
This is cute.
Rashad looked like he was going to smash
him.
He took a picture with a friend though
because I think it was photoshop Steve
that made a.
He made a photoshop of like a shot of
inside of a plane and see everyone's
sitting down and see a bunch of people
and you know,
sometimes you know when you're on a
plane and going overseas and everyone's
crashed out at night,
you know what I mean?
You're walking,
you go take a piss.
And everyone,
everyone has their crash out face.
Right?
So he put like all those famous knockout
faces on people on a planet.
And you were in there too.
I think you were wide awake though.
You're wide awake and all of these like
beat door knocked
on over here so far was one of the
greatest photoshops of all time.
I don't know where it's at though.
That's just a price that you pay if
you're going to be a part of that world,
that world,
if you,
when you get an insane amount of glory,
you know,
but you only get that glory because
there's a risk of getting the opposite
of that.
Jamie Foxx was talking about the other
day.
We were talking about Michael Jordan
that a lot of people don't even know who
Michael Jordan is.
They just know,
Oh,
you the cry baby face you.
That made me face.
People see that meme and you cease to
become an individual.
Been crying in that meeting.
What was the original source of that?
I don't know.
What was the interview?
I think it was hall of fame induction in
the hall.
I was talking about his haters.
He was calling out his haters really in
his hall of fame can here that God.
It's one of the craziest hall of fame
speeches ever.
It made people reevaluate how they feel
about them.
Some people lost all respect.
I want to hear that.
Some people understood it.
He's talking shit about like reporters
and coaches and hair play.
It's kind of telling the truth,
I'm sure,
but it's just fascinating to listen to.
Oh No,
this isn't it.
This is like how to fail and still be a
winner and all that shit.
Here it goes here.
This shit.
Twenty three minutes launch.
That's okay.
Just give me a little volume.
Let's get to the good part.
Yeah.
Kind and said,
yeah,
I do it.
And that was a disrespect to,
into my Carolina guys.
They all know them.
I'm a true Blue Carolina guide to the
heart,
you know,
coach Smith,
Larry Brown,
Sam Perkins,
James Worthy,
all of those guys.
Well,
it all starts with my,
my parents.
Uh,
you guys see all the highlights.
What is,
what is it about me that you guys don't
know?
Uh,
as I sat up and I watch all the other
recipients stand up here and they give
them the history and so many things I
didn't know about Jerry Sloan and know
he lived on the farm,
but I didn't know he was in a small
classroom from first grade to the eighth
grade.
Uh,
even David Robinson,
obviously I've known David for some time
and
we're going to lose the audience here.
Let's see.
I don't know what the part where he got
mad at people,
but he was maybe a youtube.
Michael Jordan insults gets mad.
Oh,
he mad.
Oh yeah,
something like that.
Michael.
Michael Jordan.
How about Michael Jordan?
Oh,
he mad.
Jamie's eating that cake.
Shake those things to share.
I think I have one fuck right now.
A bunch in the frazier.
Frigerator back there.
They're all Quito to.
Yeah,
give me one of them.
Yeah.
No affiliation with this company.
Ladies and gentlemen.
They're just good.
I don't know shit about them.
They might be monsters.
Yeah,
those are good man.
you got to shake it a little bit.
There you go.
They're very thick.
It's like a,
um,
like a milkshake or some shit.
What flavors are strawberry?
Powerful.
Right.
Um,
so what did you think about the Cyborg?
I felt like
it was kind of weird seeing Tanya
evenger.
So outsized,
you know,
fighting Cyborg,
who's like,
yeah,
it's real thick.
Like sometimes I eat it with a spoon.
What'd you think about that fight?
Cyborg is just too goddamn good.
Tania Singer,
she's the old girl.
She's tough and she's out of her weight
class.
She almost didn't have a chance almost.
You know what I mean?
She had a chance but wasn't the best
chance and sideboard fought a very
technical fight.
She's such a good striker.
Jesus super technical now too.
You see she's not taking too many crazy
chances.
She's just picking our spots.
She's a machine and she's really good on
the ground.
Too hard to take down.
Hereso Breslin's good.
Her work ethics.
Insane.
She's legit brown belt,
right?
Is it Jean?
Is She?
I believe she is.
Last I heard.
I didn't know.
Maybe she's got a black but,
but she's legit.
What was impressive to me that,
you know,
like evenger was like trying to be
crafty and move around and be an
unorthodox and throwing a good job.
And she was looking for a response.
Just she was just outgun but Cyborg
didn't just try to gorilla fucker.
You know what?
I know she didn't just try to check her,
chase her down and smash her.
She picked apart out her,
did a great,
a great job of hacking at the legs,
landon shots,
and then once she had her time to
evergreen.
I'd love that girl.
You know what's,
she's tough as fuck,
man.
Just one of the coolest things about mma
is how openmindedness we are with
lesbians,
right?
I mean we don't even.
It's no big deal at all with girls.
Put her on the countdown show.
Two girls.
The Nunez is the champ.
Yes.
And no one knows.
We're like totally cool.
We're all,
you know Tom [inaudible] on instagram
live making out with chicks at bars
drinking.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
She's,
she's a party girl and you're allowed to
be a big old lesbian.
Yeah.
We're so open minded.
Guys were still in Jesus.
Only one dude want to do that I know of.
That's openly gay.
Gay Porn.
It was on tough.
Oh,
wait a minute.
There's an ultimate versus name Dakota,
Dakota Cochrane,
I think his name was cock ring.
No Cochran.
That's his last name right there.
That was like a sub.
That was a part of the show.
That's what they were talking about.
Damn.
Okay.
There's one.
Yeah,
hold on.
I'm still,
we're way behind.
We're way behind because there should be
at least,
but I don't necessarily mean there
should be saying.
Okay.
I think he was just saying he did gay
porn.
I'm out.
You know what?
I love gay people.
My favorite singer of all time.
He's a Favi gang.
Uh,
anyways.
I have no problem with problem with
people being gay.
I think they should come out.
You know,
I lived in West Hollywood for almost 20
years.
You were surrounded by gay people.
Every time I visit,
you either swim to a river.
Gay people come to your house.
Yeah.
If you got,
if you're a guy,
you were still in Jesus' times,
unfortunately.
I mean,
maybe,
maybe it's not
the best thing that come out if you're
an m and a right,
but it's for comedy.
Nobody gives a fuck.
Football people care,
right?
You can be.
Can you be openly gay,
openly gay in football.
How many guys does one or two?
There's that one guy came out right
before the draft and you got right now
there's a few now about how many.
I mean not tons.
It's probably equal to the population.
Maybe like 10 percent.
No.
Well way football.
No Way.
Guys,
why do you think there's 50 openly gay
football players want to believe?
I want to believe you.
Well,
Google going to say I'm going to say
too.
Okay.
You say to say to I say five.
Jamie,
what do you say?
Say something I wasn't saying.
I'll just be right close to the average.
So it's like what?
Eight to 10 percent.
So it's probably like 30,
$40 out of the closet is what I'm
talking about this.
No,
no,
no.
That's what I'm talking about.
The national average is not considered
out of the closet.
Does it?
Nationally?
Just how many people are gay?
Yes,
but how many people are out of the
closet in the NFL?
I say there's one or two says there's
been a lot,
but there have been 11 known gay
players.
Nana and they all got.
Come on.
They're all there now,
but it's interesting.
We're not that open.
No guys are not that open.
There's a lot of players.
Think about how many players there are.
Yeah.
All right.
Now let's go this way.
What percentage of the population is gay
versus what percentage of the population
is out of the closet?
Oh Shit.
I think if you had to guess
of all of all the gay people in the
United States,
I would say I'm going to guess 50
percent are out of the closet.
Fifty one new thing.
Thirty or out of the.
Yeah,
it could be 30.
It could be 10.
Depending on where you live.
If you're in California,
you're still in the closet.
You're probably a UFC fighter.
Were you around when the Edmonton fight
happens?
Are you around during that week?
What day you got to do a fight
companion.
This is a kind of interesting.
Um,
this is totally unrelated to this
weekend.
This is actually,
what is it?
September ninth.
September ninth?
Yeah.
Is that a Saturday?
Saturday.
I'm,
I'm there on Friday it Edmonton for um,
you're doing two shows at this
auditorium.
I'm,
uh,
the jubilee auditorium to two shows that
this theater,
but I'm not doing the paper due the next
night.
Okay.
So we'll do a fight compatible.
I go back home.
Yeah.
It was weird because it's a,
it's a main event.
It's a mighty mouse versus a Ray Borg.
And Amanda Nunez Ares Valentina
Shevchenko,
but there,
I don't think they're anticipating that
it's going to be a,
a high pay per view cell.
Know.
Let's do it.
That sounds like fun.
Yeah,
it's on.
See.
I would like to get callan and shot,
but shops become too fucking successful.
He's too successful.
That fucking
baller.
He's traveling all over the place.
Selling out everywhere he's selling out
theaters has been doing standup for like
six weeks.
He sounds out.
He's been doing it more than that.
He's been doing it like a year,
but he's selling out everywhere down.
Dude.
He did what I said.
I was like,
I was telling all these other comedians.
I say,
you see what you've seen here.
I go,
this is what happens when an athlete
shows you how lazy you guys are.
Like this guy was like just starting
out,
but he actually works at it.
He does like a ton of sets.
He writes a ton.
Like he actually puts in the time,
like that's what athletes do.
Comics like to pretend they're working
and they fuck off a lot and keep doing
the same machine material for 10 years
and shop is like out there.
So again,
I'm no expert at comedy,
but it's,
I think in my opinion,
it's a lot like Jujitsu.
You gotta practice and refund.
It's a lot like writing music because
you can,
you.
If you're going to rely on just going up
there and riff and fuck,
good luck,
good luck.
It's like trying to write a song like,
okay,
we're going to record a song.
We have no idea what we're going to do,
but we're going to jam.
And he all right,
and then we'd go and that's the hit
song.
The odds of that happening,
super slim.
You've got to record a jam,
pick out a little pieces,
Polish it,
add this two months later,
oh,
you got a middle part.
Now a month later you got the intro.
It's all coming together.
Might take eight months to get that bit
together.
You know,
you're just constantly going back and
forth.
That's how music is put together and
that's how Jujitsu's put together.
You've got to constantly refine your
game.
You're out there getting ready,
what are you doing wrong?
What's working?
Let's stick to what's working with.
Add some new shit,
learning from other people,
techniques and being open minded,
understanding that your body is magical
and it'll do anything you wanted to do.
You just got to tell it over and over
and over again to a point where it does
it by itself,
without you even knowing what the hell
is going on and it's unconscious.
You could do anything.
You could play piano,
you can play a guitar.
It's like,
Oh,
I tried guitar,
but it's too hard.
You just didn't practice.
That's all.
Anybody could play guitar.
Anybody can play piano songs.
Your neurons fire correctly.
It's just your hands move just takes
time.
You got in a motorcycle accident and you
smash your hands and you're like this.
You can't play piano,
but I'm just saying if you have normal
limbs,
you could play piano,
could play guitar,
you can do anything.
You could.
You could do anything.
You can learn Jujitsu.
You can box.
You can play basketball.
He never played basketball in your life
and you're 55 years old.
If you practiced hard for a year,
it'd be I.
I know people don't want to believe that
though.
It's hard for them to believe it because
they're not reminded of it all the time.
That's why a lot of people coming from
Jujitsu and martial arts in general,
they become successful because through
Jujitsu you're constantly reminded that
you can suck at something and then you
get pretty good at it and then you
mastered and then it's unconscious.
You reminded that every time you go to
Jujitsu everyday you're reminded,
damn,
I can do this with anything,
and people do it with their business.
They go,
all I gotta do is do hustle in the in
the Gi,
Jujitsu of business
and make it happen or whatever you want
to do.
You're reminded like,
Shit.
You like it.
When I say magical,
it's not a metaphor.
It is magical because your body will do
shit on its own.
Like when you like when you're doing
Jujitsu,
sometimes I come up with moves.
I don't know what the fuck I did.
I did something I have no idea and then
it comes up again because I've
programmed and drilled my body so much
and has so many things that I trained it
to do a on instincts that it's kind of
like a suggestion thing.
Like when you hit youtube and they kind
of know what you like and here's the
suggestions,
like your body will go.
He always does this and he always does
that and he always does this
unconsciously.
Man,
he might like this and then you're like,
oh shit.
What was that?
It's like your body can someone else
came up with that and then the next time
you do like,
there it is again.
That's how most of the moves that are
transitions that I get good at.
They come up like on their own and then
the third time we got I got it and then
I videotape,
but then I've videotaped myself doing
it.
I'm like,
Shit,
I didn't even know I was doing that.
It was just like,
your body will make shit up for you.
You everybody.
Not just me.
It's everybody.
You just gotta learn how to capture it.
It's like comedy p.
people love comedy because they go see a
comedian and he's saying all this shit
that they agree with and they're
laughing and going,
yeah,
I think that this,
this comedian is amazing.
He saying shit that if you're laughing,
you agree with that.
Like you all the shit that he said
you've set and people around you have
said it.
You just didn't notice it as something
to use on stage.
So once you.
It's just like music when you.
Every time you listen to music,
like for me,
anytime I listen to music and I like
something musically,
which is rare,
I'm going to find out everything about
that song.
There's that.
I don't ever get lazy with that.
I find out who sang the song,
I downloaded the song,
I analyze a song like,
what is it about this song that makes it
so great?
Why am I getting chills listening to the
song?
Why do I have this song on repeat?
You know,
that's.
I'm trained musically to always try to
capture golden nuggets.
Every time I hear it,
oh,
I'll be in a middle of a conversation in
Japan at Tgi Fridays in Tokyo and in the
distance a song would come on and I'm in
the conversation with some people and I
hear it and it just.
I know that I tell the people I'm with,
I'll be right back.
I gotta find out what the song is.
I'll write it down them.
I just do the other Dj.
That's kind of a DJ thing.
So my point is it's same thing with
Jujitsu.
It same thing with comedy.
It's same thing with music.
You just gotTa.
It's all around you.
You just gotTa look for it.
You've got to train yourself to look
for.
Maybe you have to write shit on your
hand to train,
remind yourself,
think,
think about.
Then once that becomes your instinct
once looking for shit and recognizing
should always be on the call for Shit.
Like uh,
for instance,
like editors do to edit videos every
time they're watching a movie,
what are they doing?
They're breaking down the editing.
You're right,
of course like movie makers are breaking
down the lighting.
They're watching them and we feel the
hidden directors of movies,
you know,
a lot of ways,
like the directors,
they get all these ideas,
they put it together,
but a lot of times you'd get on a
television show as well to editor will
make these passes at things when they
give you like a,
like an editor's first cut.
And a lot of times it's like,
you know,
the director would look at and go,
I liked that.
Like that.
That's good.
You don't get any better.
You got to have an editor who,
who knows,
who knows this.
He,
yeah.
You got to be talented.
Not just some slave that's gonna cut
shit together.
And there's a lot of talent and the
editing you to be,
especially in television shows.
Right?
Or I guess in movies too,
you know?
Yeah,
I get the editors that I got working
from his hot level.
Amazing that editor like that movies are
still in a theater now,
so one of the rare things you do when
you go somewhere like just to,
to get,
uh,
some,
some sort of art where it's not live,
you're going to go to a place still,
like they still have them like that and
I don't know if I'd been brainwashed
because I love,
I love to,
but I'm just saying it's weird because
it's like one of the few places we have
left,
we'll,
we'll go and take in media at a,
at a specific location.
We all meet,
like we go for a live show,
we'll go for a live show,
but if you,
you're not going to go to see like have
a fake band somewhere.
Gigantic screen that's like a 100 times
bigger than you.
And the sound is amazing.
Yeah.
So there's all that crazy though.
Then it's cool sitting with people and
when they laugh you laugh and it's
continual.
You want to laugh more when there's
other people around,
but you run the risk of douchebags run
the risk that people talk and people
talk and the people that do that violate
the sacred laws of the movie theater.
You got to go in which big old Como de
shades and a beanie and a fake beard.
Crazy.
You know,
beards are.
So in these days,
what happened to the fake beard market?
Like,
why isn't there like dudes like wearing
fake beards to clubs and you know what I
mean,
like posing fake shit.
Girls can wear fake asses.
They can have fake tits.
Fake,
fair,
fair.
It's kind of like there's a lot of
things that aren't fair.
And that's one thing that they got,
you know,
we can't have,
we can't be the same.
So whoever was deciding on men and women
like,
okay,
you get this,
you get that.
It isn't fair.
Like the women were like,
okay,
if you're gonna,
uh,
you get uh,
you guys,
you know,
they're,
they,
they can't control it.
Guys are attracted to girls with nice
bodies fit by.
Generally.
There are some guys just nice bodies,
like there's something about actual fake
tits that's hot because it's like,
wow,
this girl is.
She's in the deck so much.
She just wants to be like ultra
attractive in a cartoonish way.
Like look at those giant fake tits jet.
Some guys,
some guys are like,
I don't like fake tits.
They're still some of those guys out
there that there's like a 15 percent of
the population.
Eventually another generation,
those will be all gone and fake.
Tits would just be accepted by all men,
but fake ass.
Woo.
That's going to take a couple of
generations.
That's going to happen.
This.
Nobody
is cool with fake asses.
Nobody.
That's the worst shit ever.
The don't get it.
Girls don't even think about it.
Yeah,
but the gray area is this fat thing
they're doing and what is not a fake
ass,
but they're taking fat grafting fat
that's still grow parts.
Do some squats,
do some squats.
Anybody could have a great body,
just do some squats.
Not that's not true.
There's some people out there that got
some fucked up.
There's nothing wrong with hillbilly
stick.
Stick people,
those people,
you got to get good at sucking Dick,
you gotta eat ass.
You eat ass and sucked it.
I don't want to.
They think they have no choice to get
the fat.
Stuff's want to reengineer.
The older you get,
the more women eat.
As I was reading this thing about
Crispr,
that they're starting to use crispr for
a Jew for embryos now,
and they think they're really close to
genetically engineering.
The first people that become viable,
actual humans.
Do you know what Crispr is?
No,
dude,
it's like photoshop for jeans.
They're looking at this scientist edit
human embryos for the first time in the
US.
They're,
they're using this new technology which
is way more complicated than my puny
brain has the ability to describe,
but it's a gene editing tool called
crispr and there is a,
an episode,
another episode of radio lab that's
about crispr that it might be like a
good way for you to get an entertaining
but descriptive,
uh,
explanation of it.
But,
uh,
they're,
they're going to be able to at least
someday in the future if this keeps
going,
they keep perfecting this.
They're going to be able to edit things
out of people like they're going to be
able to take away the the gene for
Alzheimer's,
you know?
I don't know.
What do you mean?
You don't know?
I don't know.
They always say shit like in the future
doing it now and they're doing it now.
Like there's real science behind this.
Like you could,
you could follow the science.
They're editing things the same way.
They're making photoshop the same way.
They're making that new thing that
allows them to edit videos.
They're gonna edit genes.
How about those contact lenses where you
can play video games and you're seeing
some Microsoft made and stuff?
Yeah,
I don't think they have that yet.
I think they have glasses so far,
but I don't think they have contact
lenses.
Contact Lenses.
Retinal.
Yeah.
It's going to happen.
If you could do it with a,
with the glass,
like Google.
You ever see Google glass?
You ever put that on?
It was weird that Google glass isn't
around anymore.
They've got some new applications for
it.
But what it was like was like,
um,
like a glass frame and yeah.
This little thing in front of you like a
little window,
like a tiny little tv that was sitting
in front of your eyes because it's clear
and on that little window you could see
through it,
but you could also see like a navigation
directions and uh,
you could google things and have it
brought up in front of you and maybe
steal shit.
Yeah,
like some,
some movie shit.
But it was like the Internet,
like you're making phone calls.
I know these guys,
you know,
they're not,
I have no idea who people are.
I mean,
don't
like drinking it.
Yeah.
You need to stab.
Well,
let's not do it while the podcast going
on and just sucking on that thing and
chewing it.
A spoon.
Okay.
Real quick.
S black helicopters.
Um,
they're good though.
I like them.
You got a spoon or no?
Eddie Bravo.
Abandoned you in the middle of a podcast
for a knife.
I'm sorry.
You offered it defaults.
Cave shakes blowing up.
Now their stock's going through the
roof.
What were we just talking about?
This ar stuff.
This is going to be built into apple's
new operating system,
allows you to read how big something is.
It's a virtual tape measure that you
just hold your camera up to stuff and
you can talk like they're right here.
They're showing you that is how accurate
it is.
But like it see the tape measure staying
there.
They're measuring the size of a picture
frame diagonally and it stays in space.
Uh,
if I'm saying,
if you get what I'm saying,
like I do the three d space,
it knows where you're modeling depending
on how far away you are from it and
those.
Wow.
The other weird thing is by watching
that show,
the planet of the Apps,
they just started on apple music,
but I think it was in the first episode.
The Sky shows an APP that he made that I
think apple bought.
Eventually they're adding into this
operating system.
They're mapping the inside of every,
everywhere that your camera can take,
a place or a shooting.
So,
uh,
inside here eventually we'll be all
mapped.
And this guy said that he,
he would own the map.
That's why apple bottoms.
Now apple's going to own it,
so they're essentially going to be able
to have the inside three d maps of
every,
in every building in the world or at
least wherever and telling me what that
sorry.
But uh,
it's built into the phone.
So there's other cool stuff too,
so they can map everything just based
on.
We'll get there eventually.
Yeah.
Like,
so they did something came out about
Roombas,
like the room are currently tracking at
the inside of everybody's houses and
apartments and I don't know what the
hell they're going to do with that data,
but people got scared they're going to
sell it to someone can be good.
You know what I mean?
How is that going to be good?
We're doing this to protect you.
How?
It's not about protection necessarily,
but it could be used.
You guys have trillions of dollars
missing.
It could be useful.
It's not the same people,
Eddie.
Yeah.
I mean if Jesus Christ you keep making
these things are not people as the
Illuminati that run the government.
This can help blind pizza technologists.
These are people that are creating the
greatest stuff.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Okay,
yeah,
I mean this is not the illuminati making
this stuff.
Eddie.
This is,
this is technologist as apple.
Yeah.
The,
apple's not the fucking Illuminati.
I didn't sell the apple did get in
trouble recently.
Do you know what they did in China?
They,
uh,
they made a deal with the Chinese
government to um,
to take aps down from their APP store
that allow you to circumnavigate their,
a censorship system.
People were very,
very upset at them because what
essentially is a,
they're saying that apps are illegal in
China,
so they're not allowing them on the
apple store,
but they're illegal in China because
they allow them to get away from
government censorship.
So government censorship has a certain
lock down on what you're allowed to look
at online.
Here it is.
Apple Removes Apps from the Chinese
store that help Internet users of aid
censorship.
Very disappointing to people because
they feel like apple kind of like,
feels like maybe they have to do this
other New York Times trying to get us to
pay.
How dare you?
New York Times.
No one's paying for articles online.
Just stop,
just stop with the FEC pays for articles
online.
Who gets newspapers,
still have your old.
Do you ever get one of your in a hotel
and they offer you the USA Today to see
what the fuck the world pay attention to
man USA Today.
That's like a CNN of newspapers.
If you had to guess like what percentage
of people actually read the whole USA
Today?
Every day.
Two percent.
No Way.
Less than one percent.
Less than one for sure.
One hundred percent,
but that was just making a point to,
well,
it's just like a e entertainment news
for the world,
you know?
It's like,
it's like very surface.
Yeah.
I mean it's just you're supposed to get
it at a hotel,
like what's going on?
Oh,
we won the football game.
What do you think about that?
Other religions of Donald Trump and CNN.
What?
What I think was crazy was it cnn went
and found the guy who made the meme and
put it online and they scared him.
Gangster,
right?
Yeah.
Like what are you doing?
Matt?
And them blackmail them,
but what,
how crazy is that?
Like you don't think that that's funny.
Is that what you're saying?
Like he was in the wwe,
you know,
donald was in the wwe,
you knew that that video is available
and they put a CNN thing over your face.
You're actually mad at that.
You at that.
You're not mad at the six point
$5,000,000,000,000
missing,
but you're mad at that.
That seems pretty fucking crazy to me.
That seems pretty crazy to me.
You're going to go after a guy who made
a comical meme about the president body
slamming you,
made him apologize publicly.
Dude.
How many memes are there of a sucking
dicks?
GotTa be thousands,
right?
It's like the golden rule of the
Internet.
If there's a photo of you online
somewhere,
someone has photoshop to dick in your
mouth and now it's going to get even
crazier.
There's probably at least 50 gay.
You just showed me the one you showed me
of you and me in a wrestling statue with
the dudes grabbing the Dudek.
Yup.
That's what photoshop,
Steve,
but what it.
My point is that they would get so mad
at that that they would go after the guy
who made it.
That sort of reinforces the side of
trump.
Like people don't get that.
They don't understand that if you,
you,
you have something that's comical,
right?
Like that meme of Donald Trump's slam
and CNN and then you go find the guy who
was just joking around,
made a little animated Gif joking
around,
put it online.
I thought it was funny.
Everybody a laugh,
you know all he smashed.
In fact fake news.
Ha Ha,
ha ha.
And you go and scare that guy.
You go and scare that guy.
What are you doing?
What's going on?
You know what's scarier?
You're CNN.
What's scarier than that is that there's
still people that watch that shit every
day.
Yeah.
After that,
after knowing that you're going to still
watch it and believe it.
The other thing was the store,
they made up about Russian contacts
about,
uh,
there's like three reporters had to
resign.
It was store that was on cnn to like
greatly exaggerated.
I think CNN is,
they just want to start shit.
I think it's not the one to make money.
They just want to start shit.
I think it's part.
I think it's part of the agenda.
I think this is what I think they feel
like if there's an enemy out there and
the enemy is the new president,
they think there's an enemy and they
feel like they're going to war with the
enemy and when you have a bunch of
soldiers that are going to war for the
enemy,
some of them do some unscrupulous shit.
Like these people that got.
They had to resign because the story
with Russia with the fake facts.
I forget what the actual thing was,
but CNN disavowed their article,
pulled it down,
removed it whole deal.
Three journalists leaving CNN after
retracted article.
CNN journalists,
including the executive editor in charge
of a new investigative unit,
have resigned after the publication of a
Russia,
Russia related article that was
retracted.
So you can go into details as you wanted
it.
You know what?
What if.
What if the CNN Donald Trump feud is
like pro wrestling?
What if they're just laughing and
they're just slinging shit back and
forth talking to a guy the other day
that thinks that he thinks it's all
about setting up China,
he said said,
it's all about us going to war these
other countries.
He thinks there's all these distractions
are happening and that's what's.
And positioning North Korea and China on
the side of North Korea and you know
it's crazy by North Korea,
the most.
They're the most demonized country on
the planet.
Oh,
they're always testing missiles or
testing,
miss it.
Since the Korean War.
You know how many countries they've
invaded and killed innocent civilians?
Zero.
How many countries have we invaded and
killed?
Millions of civilians like 20 or 30
since the Korean War,
but they're the bad guy.
They're the bad guy.
They're not invading anybody.
They've never invaded anybody.
We invade people all the fucking time
and kill innocent children and come on,
this is a big show going on.
There's nothing that's true,
but it is a dictatorship.
Like what's a scary dictatorship?
They have no control.
No,
no,
no.
It's not.
It's not the people who have been there
and studied it.
No one disagrees,
Eddie.
I think it's out of control at a prison
country.
Yeah.
They're all in prison by the show.
I think it's,
there's no show and Eddie,
they do.
They do and it is scary,
but they're a minor league problem,
like in comparison to a lot of other
problems that are in the line.
I don't believe that because CNN pushes
it so everybody approaches it.
Eddie,
I think there's no one out there that's
saying that North Korea is not a
military threat.
Are there not some sort of a military
dictatorship?
I think it's a distraction
thing on it.
I don't think there's that many people
out there and never invaded anybody.
We've invaded the country,
but this guy's still a psychopath that's
running this whole country in 2017.
That scares the fuck out of psychopath.
So we got a lot of people did Michael.
Malice does.
He's an author that I had on the podcast
that wrote a book about Kim Jong.
Uhm,
and you know,
he was describing was a una ill,
ill isn't a new guy.
No,
that's the young guy,
Kim.
Kim Jong Un is the dad,
the dad.
The Dad is the kid.
The new one.
Okay,
so that was Kim Jong Il,
but it's called dear reader.
It's a very,
very good book and interesting to find
out how fucked up it is over there.
It's a system that's set up so that
everybody's in prison by it.
Everybody tells on everybody else,
like their setup to tell on each other,
like the people that have escaped and
they've left and gone to South Korea and
they'll tell the stories about the
prison camps.
People are born in prison camps over
there.
Eddie,
I think their prisoner actors.
Oh,
come on,
Jesus.
I don't get mad because I say that.
Why am I going to get killed for saying
a whole group of the whole country's a
bunch of actors to getting a check.
I think the presenters and they're
forced to do parades.
Yeah,
they're definitely prisoners.
They definitely forced to pray.
Exactly.
Yeah,
like the whole country's a prison.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm.
That's what I said,
but they're not actors acting when
they're being filmed.
The guys,
they're acting.
They're not real.
They're not being sincere.
They're acting.
They're forced to act the prisoners.
But wait a minute,
do you think that this country is under
the control of a military dictatorship
and everyone's terrified of doing
anything wrong?
You think that.
Okay,
so you think that.
What do you mean by they're acting
though?
There's.
They're all terrified.
Like how are they acting?
In what way they're.
They're acting like they're in love with
Kim Jong.
Terrified.
Yeah.
They all do that.
That's,
that's they.
They were arrested.
They went to jail.
A bunch of people did for not crying
hard enough when his dad died.
Not crying hard enough like people did
like six months of hardly come up with
all that shit.
He got a haircut and he made everyone
get the same haircut.
Look into that.
That's.
Yeah,
that's a fake story that everyone thinks
is true,
that he got a haircut and he made every
man in the country get a haircut or they
get killed or something or get thrown in
prison.
I never saw that you.
It's bullshit.
Maybe did maybe that gangster high top
fade or die because motherfuckers don't
like high top fade or die.
They don't have shit.
What do you mean they don't have nuclear
weapons?
You don't think so?
Well,
let's just bring you to a Washington DC
and clean this up.
That's.
I'm just,
I don't believe Shit.
You know,
robin,
trillions of dollars I think.
I think you should not believe in
anything coming from the mainstream
media.
Anything.
If they're all pushing it,
then it can't be the truth.
North Korea themselves.
I mean they definitely launched a
missile.
The missile they launched yesterday say
they don't believe it.
No.
Who's they?
That's what they said.
That Fox News.
Everybody.
They're all.
It's all mainstream media.
So do you think they're all in on it?
I think it's a distraction.
I think there's some serious shit going
on in Washington DC and they need that
shit.
Oh,
they're there.
They're sending out missiles again and
everyone's afraid of world war three.
It's two gangs.
Not Anybody.
We've invaded 30 countries or 20 or 30
countries since the Korean War.
We've killed millions of innocent people
on some bullshit ass wars and we're
worried about North Korea.
That's ridiculous.
True.
But again,
that we're brainwashed,
or maybe they are a military
dictatorship with nuclear power.
I'm very suspect experts.
Latest North Korean missile could strike
Boston in New York City.
Eddie Bravo.
Skeptical.
Hippo face.
I mean,
this is a trap,
man.
Got a beautiful haircut though.
Look at that.
Sweet.
Did you know in the Korean War we made
this mainstream news?
We made 18 cities disappearing.
It was horrible.
What they did,
they made the Soviets get the fuck out.
The Soviets left and and after the
Korean War,
the United States was like,
what are we going to do with that?
China says we'll take over.
So since the Korean War,
it hasn't been officially Soviets.
The Soviets officially left and then
China took over.
They kind of manage it and govern it.
I think it does.
I think it's just like a little prison
country that they use to.
They used as the bad guy.
I think.
I wouldn't be surprised if Kim junk
doesn't even live in Korea.
Just all Hologram does.
It.
Just take videos,
if you watch the videos easily faked,
easily fit.
There is no proof of anything.
There's no proof of shit.
You're right.
They're showing video,
but missile going up.
Oh,
I believe that after they still in
trillions of dollars,
we we shouldn't believe shed a smart man
wouldn't believe shit that the missiles
that are getting launched in the area.
So all the people like missiles,
missiles say that.
I didn't say so.
That's why I assume they don't have
missiles.
If we thought they.
I'm talking about.
I'm talking about North Korea.
They have missiles.
That's what they tell you,
that the Russians and the Russian sell
them shit.
That's what the Chinese,
the Russians,
everything.
They say they who's they?
The same people that stole the trillions
of dollars,
stole the trillions are also running CNN
thing.
It's all connected.
Definitely that.
That's the truth.
They are all connected.
There's.
I don't think you can have everything
connected if they're going back and
forth with each other.
Like,
look what's happening in between Fox
News and CNN,
right?
Look at,
look at.
Look at the,
the,
the internal battery gets fake.
Wow.
He was a Republican and Democrats.
It's a fake fucking and not really in
competition with each other either.
They don't care who gets more ratings,
more money individually.
Individually.
People are worried about their own check
in their own family.
So individually,
yes,
but at the top it's just a show and I
don't believe she had coming from them
too much fake and six moon landings.
Come on,
let me,
let me ask you this.
Let me ask you this.
Where do you think.
Because one of the things that's
happened for sure is as time has moved
on,
as technology has gotten more and more
powerful and the ability to do all the
stuff that
we can do now with our phones,
all the information that you can get
like almost instantly with your phone,
like when is it going to reach a point
where no one has any control over anyone
else because it seems to me that that's
inevitable.
Seems to me that the idea of these big
units of these big groups having control
over massive amounts of people.
I think at a certain point in time,
if technology keeps moving the way it
is,
more and more people have more and more
ability to communicate.
You're not gonna be able to hide things.
The daughter right now,
and I think we're going to reach a point
in time where they can't do that,
like they could do that so much easier
in the sixties.
They could do anything in the sixties.
It was easy.
So
it was so easy to fake deaths in the
sixties,
fifties,
fake everything.
It was so easy.
No one knew shit.
It was Jack Ruby runs up on Lee Harvey
Oswald just shoots him in the guts in
front of everybody.
Just let this guy run out him with a gun
in his hand.
They're bringing them in.
They got.
We've got,
um,
Lee Harvey Oswald.
We got um.
Oh,
what's that guy?
What's he doing?
Running our way?
Hey,
is that a gun?
Bang.
He just shoots him right in the stomach
and meanwhile he's probably not even
dead.
That looks so staged.
Maybe Lee Harvey Oswald.
They gotta do we gotta send you to an
island while they shot that?
Dude,
you could see the bullet hit him,
shoots him right in the guts.
I think there's land that the elite have
that no one knows about.
Man.
That's what I think I would if I was the
elite,
how it ask some Shenandoah.
We don't need to tell these
motherfuckers everything.
You think they think that the people
running shit or like we need to tell the
people we need to.
They need to know they,
they,
they have a right to know.
Clinton does.
Like most of his days think he's just
got a bunch of chicks he calls up.
Hey,
I don't know.
But when you watch the stroke and the
resistance,
there's a.
They may be bullshit,
but there's some was the Clinton
chronicles.
The Clinton chronicles is a documentary
made in the nineties that you could find
on youtube and it goes through his
career in Arkansas and in the coke and
all that stuff with the CIA.
MENA,
Arkansas.
Wow.
Well,
George,
senior vice president with Ronald
Reagan,
the Contra.
All that Shit,
man.
There's a war on drugs.
That's a scam.
There's.
They're not trying to stop.
No.
God Damn drugs,
they'll bust the Mexican cartel here and
there just to just to say they're doing
shit,
but they're taking all that money.
Then once again,
we need to fight this drug war.
They get all his fucking money.
Just you think that it's just like the
moon and all the space?
Shit.
I just Bill Clinton's doing right now.
He's probably having a good time.
I think he's having.
Do you take to him?
I think he's having a fucking great time
right now to tell you the truth.
Do you think they got him set up today?
He's got like a sweet house and they
bring them grapes and shit.
He lays down.
He's.
There's no one's ever going to buy this
movie about Barry still coming out at
the end of the summer.
American made five.
Going to be Tom Cruise and unreal.
Is this going to be?
Come on.
It's good propaganda film.
Huh?
It's not a felony if you're doing it for
the good guys.
Wow.
Yeah,
they're gonna.
They're gonna.
Make him look really bad one.
I wonder if Fensa
won't be able to just say,
hey,
this long time ago,
how can they make it look?
They're going to make it look like we
don't do it anymore.
He was being sent a.
He was barry seal's was a pilot.
He was a trailer.
Tom Cruise looking sexy as ever.
Bad ass pile.
How does he stay?
He was a bad ass pilot.
He had his pilot's license at 15 and so
the CIA recruited him.
That's mainstream.
They say I recruited him because he was
a bad ass pilot.
Who?
This who was the trailer is really good.
Good.
That's he's covered in coke and he gets
out of a fucking plane.
Covered in coke,
steals a kid's bike.
Wow.
He crashed rounds at a plain film.
How does Tom Cruise Day looking?
Thirty five.
What is he doing?
His scientologists,
but what are they doing?
Are they doing maybe blood.
They like running like those little a
cotton gin looking things over his face.
Have you heard?
Have you heard someone Europe?
This could be bullshit.
Oh no,
but people like teens that they donate
blood.
Old people are buying young blood and
getting transfusions.
Europe,
it's here in silicone valley or they're
doing it for real.
You who's a famous billionaire?
Tell me about that.
What do you know are they found that if
you inject young mice with the or old
mice rather with the blood of young
mice,
it makes them act like a young mouse.
It's just the way they hit for
Millennia.
Well,
it sounds like vampires.
Shit.
Forget about Illuminati.
Sounds like vampire stuff.
Elizabeth Elizabeth bathory stuff.
So they,
um,
they are doing this now where they take
like these young healthy guys and they
donate blood and then you go there and
they take that blood and pump it into
your system and they fill your body up
with young blood.
It does it work.
Apparently it has some crazy like
rejuvenating effect on you.
So let me ask you this.
Okay?
People,
people freak out when you say the
Illuminati.
They're kidnapping kids and torturing
babies and they want,
they want it.
They want to scare the shit out of them
because they want adrenaline's blood and
they're poking holes all over analyze
blood.
Apparently.
If you scare the shit out of him,
the the adrenal gland flushes into this
is what they do.
I have.
Can I just talk?
I don't know if it's real.
I don't know if it's real,
but apparently adrenalize blood is the
most potent,
so they scare the kids and they kill him
and suck.
Either they drink their blood.
That's a conspiracy theory.
That's a conspiracy theory,
but we're already seeing this with.
We're being well being.
Slowly get.
If the blood is good for you,
for old people,
I bet some billionaire is going to go.
What about booking toddler blood?
What about that shit?
What about newborn baby blood?
I bet they're thinking.
Think about
stem cells.
Thing about stem cells.
Getting placental stem cells would think
about all the kidnaps or embryotic
700,000
to a million kidnaps a year,
so I think they're just taking babies
and using them to make rich people stay
alive forever.
What if you were rich and fucking
psychopath kid you do that?
We'll let you do that.
We can use crispr to artificially
engineered a bunch of headless kids and
you take the blood out of them.
Didn't even know you got it.
Blood is working right.
Don't want you to think baby blood would
be.
It wouldn't be a shock.
Or if you found out that baby blood is
the best,
right you this,
would that be a shock?
Is it immoral to have a warehouse filled
with headless fake kids?
They don't have any head.
They never did have a hat.
They were engineered with Crispr to have
no head and you have them hooked up to
this thing and there's still some blood
into these vats and you go there and
they tap you and you have to like look
up and recognize that these artificial
people got to be real blood.
If blood,
they're real people,
they just don't have any heads.
So they never have a chance to be alive.
They're connected to some machine.
Is this a movie?
Uh,
no.
Probably.
It's kind of like the Matrix,
right?
Kind of like the Matrix but,
but,
but we already know teen blood is
helping old people.
I think it's 25 year olds is what they
said for an adult with based on the fact
that teen blood is better than getting
like a 50 year old black.
Right?
Right.
Yes.
So that's what they're saying.
Toddler blood would be better than team
black.
Well,
here's the other thing.
Maybe you're right.
Here's the other thing that goes the
other way,
which is even more fascinating.
They took the blood of old mice and they
put it into to the young mice and the
young man started acting old,
which is kind of fucked.
Wow.
Like there's something in the blood and
they're trying to isolate what it is.
Of course,
like it just makes sense.
It's easy to believe like,
yeah,
young blood is probably better than old
blood.
Yeah.
It's probably better.
Yeah,
and that's where everything comes from.
It comes from the blood.
Everything could blood is this.
Cannabis reverses aging process in the
brain.
Studies suggest researchers restore the
memory performance of Methuselah,
methuselah mice to a juvenile stage.
Whoa.
Regressed to a two month old.
Using a cannabis active ingredient.
Whoa.
Interesting.
That's crazy.
Treatment opens up new options when it
comes to treating dementia.
Now imagine if we read was what you
needed.
I just hardcore edibles.
We need to act.
Ask Joey some questions.
He does have some stories.
We know for a fact that cannabis
basically like 90 percent cure seizures
and kids and and even in animals,
a dog dogs that have seizures.
You give him some cannabis oil,
but let me ask you this,
why does it fuck with your memory?
How come when we're high?
We're like,
what the fuck was I just talking about?
My theory is this.
It's like there's a difference between a
forgetting something and misplacing
something.
Like when you go out to vegas and you
get hammered and you black out,
there's no way someone's going to say
anything to you that's going to make
that memory come back of this or that.
They can say,
dude,
and then you grow and then you grabbed
her and then you picked her up and then
you told to get the fuck out of here and
you're like,
dude,
I don't remember any of that.
You lost your memory.
Even them reminding you and telling you
about what happened there.
You lost your memory,
but now when you're stone and you've got
all this shit going on,
there's,
you know,
we'd make blood rushes to your head so
you've got so much shit going on.
Shit gets misplaced.
You forgot what you were talking about,
but if someone reminds you of what you
were talking about,
you're like,
oh,
okay.
Then you're back on track.
You didn't eat any booze in that respect
because.
Well,
there's a difference between actually a
forgetting something and not remembering
at all.
It just complete.
You did it.
You were drunk.
You don't remember it.
There's nothing anybody can do to bring
it back.
They can tell you all about it.
You could watch it on video.
It ain't coming back.
Maybe the memory of you watching the
video will,
will,
will stay in your brain,
but no memories of.
It's never coming back with weed.
You're talking about all this shit
you're going to have.
It's you start,
you start digressing and moving to this
and jumping all over the place and go,
what did I just say?
If someone reminded you,
it'll come back.
It wasn't like,
man,
I don't remember ever talking about
that.
You were just talking about that.
No,
I don't remember that.
So it's different.
Well,
I forget sometimes when I'm talking
about,
but I don't feel yet.
Moments or instances or facts.
If you were blackout drunk,
you were a couple of times.
Hey Man.
Coffees,
those little things.
Yeah.
Everybody has gotten those moments
where.
Lockout,
where or just when you know that like
you're not seeing things the way other
people are seeing them.
Like where are like,
that's why I don't understand how
anybody could do like,
like ketamine,
like people that do like recreational
ketamine never done it.
Never done it either.
But it's scary.
You go into that k hole that they talk
about.
Sound good?
Doesn't sound good.
That doesn't sound good to me.
I don't want to do that.
It's some sort of animal tranquilizer,
right?
Something.
Thanks Bro.
What is it?
Um,
what was it called?
K Hole,
if it was called a wonder lust,
if something was called Wanderlust,
I'd be like,
let me draw it.
Yeah,
but they call it a k hole after they've
been in it.
Yeah,
it sounds horrible.
It sounds like darkness.
I don't want to go there.
I never had the desire to do something
that was going to put you in a k hole.
Fuck that.
Like acid.
Not into it.
We did that acid podcast with jelly.
I didn't think I can go.
That was the only guy.
Not on acid,
but Ari was on acid.
Joey Lee.
It was fucking hysterical.
I was like,
you gotta change the name.
You can't call it acid.
I'm not going to take anything called
acid.
That fucks me up.
That's hilarious.
And He.
They should've called it something else.
They should have solved if they just
call it Cuti Love Qd love.
Yeah.
I'll take some qt.
Love.
What's it going to do?
Oh,
just make you look you so I'll with joey
would drop some math.
You don't give a fuck man.
Yeah.
Joey's.
He's downtown gangster.
That's the yelling and everywhere to joe
has been doing a lot of travel.
He just sold out the Borgata casino in
Atlantic city.
That's not.
Yeah.
He wanted to come in and do a podcast to
promote it and he's like,
I don't even got to promote a dog hits
already.
Sold the fuck out.
Everybody's killing it.
It's Kinda crazy.
Crazy to see how uh,
how hard they're killing it on the road.
Shows podcasts,
killing it too.
Then the comedy store,
Holy Shit.
That's back in the day.
They had so many like hidden bars back
there that collected dust,
spider webs everywhere.
Now all those back rooms are being used
like the old days.
It's insane.
I've never,
I mean I was hanging out at the comedy
store all the Goddamn time with you for
like two or three years straight.
You come pick me up man.
I come out your car,
but either like,
like the baddest car on the planet is
like just waiting for me.
I'm out front.
And those moments,
you know,
the reason I bring that up is last night
after Ebi,
me and my wife drove through my
neighborhood and we went down my street.
I got out of my car,
I parked right in front of my house and
I got on my car.
I just wanted to look at it again.
I mean,
I was there for like 15 years and when I
turned around and walked back to the
car,
dude and I went back to 2001 where you'd
come and pick me up and we drive to the
comedy store.
Dude,
I had that vision.
I was just last night,
man.
It was,
it was,
it was insane.
It was crazy at that all the goddamn
time.
And the comedy store the way it is now.
Holy Shit.
Tuesday night selling out,
it stays.
Fuck.
That sounded almost every night.
Sometimes there was a main room was
rarely used.
It was just all about the alarm was
struggling,
it was struggling.
And then when you left and you had that
falling out for for awhile,
then dude darkness.
And then you come back,
boom.
It's like,
it's like Jesus is doing stand up there
now.
You know what I mean?
It's so packed and everyone loves it and
there's lines outside.
It's nuts.
It's weird.
Right?
It's weird to see because you get to see
it in the dark days.
You got to see it.
When I first started going down,
which we weren't getting a lot of
crowds.
No,
just the.
Oh,
and it's rarely that.
It took like a few years of me going
there,
selling out sellouts warrant happening
back then.
Not many maybe of Dave Chappelle came by
and did like a sad or something.
Maybe another one talk or maybe on a
Friday night it would sell out our
Saturday night and the o are.
Yeah,
but just the lr.
Not like both of them.
Can,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
And now it's nuts and every but all the
managers like,
hell yeah.
This is all an insane.
It's beautiful.
It's a beautiful thing,
man.
It's crazy.
It's the Internet to Internet and that
opened the fucking place up.
It's always been a big for texts were
crazy people to something.
That was something about that place.
That guy was there last week.
I'm Robert Apple.
Your mom provided his name?
Robert William App or via a lawyer.
I'd like to talk to him like,
you can't touch them.
You can't touch them.
You won't change.
What's the store like?
What does he say?
Is he a,
I don't know.
I mean asperger's.
He's got
something going on.
There's some issues through some,
uh,
some sort of issue.
He walked the documentary right now
getting into that.
Did you know that dude would do.
He would put on a jacket and then he
would put,
he would stuff the jacket filled with
plastic bags and walk in the rain.
He's like a sort of a homeless kind of
comedian who shows up place where he
sleeps and he's got a place and he's
been at the comedy store every week
forever,
every week.
And he's always on.
He's by himself.
No one usually talks to them.
Right.
It's kind of a nice guy and he's all.
His jokes are about marijuana.
Does he have good ones?
They're not bad.
Oh,
so he's a super weed.
Got the.
Oh yeah,
it's all about weed.
Everything's relaxed about weed.
I didn't know that.
You didn't know that.
I never let his whole act is about
marijuana.
What does he say?
Like,
Oh,
you don't have to go there and watch and
watch.
I wouldn't want to do as bits,
but yeah,
it's all about weed.
That's crazy.
I thought there's a lake.
He was a lawyer.
There's this documentary about this old
lady who basically lives at a
laundromat.
She just like,
just started hanging out there and super
nice and started doing people's laundry
and like the owner of the laundromat
just like,
let her live there.
You know,
she's just a homeless person.
She was really sweet.
Good.
She's a,
she's there all day.
Clean it up and watch.
He's like,
yeah,
I got free security.
She's nice.
I'm not going to throw her out.
And she's helping everybody.
Everybody loves her.
And then,
uh,
they did a documentary on what she,
her life.
It's pretty fascinating,
man.
I'm Zach Galifianakis take has been
taken.
He's known her for years because she's
like in Santa Monica and back when he
was a struggling actor,
he met her at the laundromat and he
became friends with her.
He takes her on red carpet.
Premiers as this date,
hooked her up there.
They have a really close relationship.
That's credit he takes.
He takes her to legit red carpet,
big ass movie premiers.
Zach's an interesting guy,
man.
He's real good friends with brody.
Really?
Brody was having some issues.
He reached out because he know I'm
friends with brody and just telling me
like,
Bro,
he's not doing so good right now.
Help out.
Try to keep an eye on him.
Don't,
don't do anything.
Nuts.
Really easy.
Uh,
he's not doing standup anymore.
What does this remind me of the story I
just heard the other day?
So I'm looking at this video up.
It's not brand new,
which I thought it was brand new.
This lady was living in this guy's
addict for a couple of,
I think a year and the way he found out
as he put a camera in because he was
finding food missing from his apartment.
Like in this kitchen,
this lady was living in his attic and
climbing down when he was gone to like
take it.
Shower food.
I think it was a year.
I want to say it might've been a little
longer.
It could have been a little less like 54
years old.
This is like that movie,
like it was in New York.
We had this little stool there.
Starts with a P.
Whoa.
A poltergeist?
No,
no.
It's a paranormal activity.
Is that all?
This is crazy.
It's good to be fake.
Look how quiet she.
So she doing this while he's asleep.
I think he was gone at work and she
probably didn't want anybody to know
that she's pissed in my sink.
What the fuck is it?
Videos.
Timelapse a little bit to some.
Skip it.
Oh my gosh.
She's sitting there and his dad,
his whole apartment that we're looking
at.
Well this is just like this kitchen.
You just put like a still camera in
there when he went to work to find out
what happened in the middle of the night
to maybe,
Whoa,
hold on,
keep going with that.
Keep going.
That where is she?
How did she get up there?
Like she went back up?
Yeah,
exactly.
How does she get back up?
Yeah.
Where did she go?
That's him,
right?
That's him.
There she is.
Okay.
So where does she go?
Did this guy to be fake?
No Way.
She could get up there.
Let's find out how she does it.
Oh Shit.
Oh.
She hears him coming in and she runs and
hides.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
It might have been the middle of the
night.
Oh my God.
He got up in the middle of the night.
She had a whole.
How is she going to get back?
How is she going to get back up there?
Been doing it every night,
but let's see it.
Let's see it
do.
That is insane.
So he leaves.
She comes back and that's it.
There's no shot of her going back.
It was just right there.
Okay,
let's see that.
Oh Shit.
It's real too.
She lives in his attic.
That's insane.
That's so
creepy.
Would say the next morning,
maybe the next morning.
Didn't I say that at the very end of
that video?
Does it say a video?
How long has she was up there for
like how long had it been?
I don't know.
Was going back to the story.
So you get the rest go like right when
she pops up,
go right back to that video please.
And right when she pops up into the
attic area.
Go a little bit further back before when
she scrambles up.
Fine.
When she scrambles up in there.
I don't see it coming out the next
morning.
Yeah.
Okay.
Him saw him the next morning.
And does he check the video and find
out?
Fuck man,
you know creepy.
That would be of your sleeping in the
house and someone's in your God Damn
Anik.
And they climbed down while you're.
While you're sleeping.
They make themselves some food and they
climb right back up there.
That's like a little human rat.
Here's where she was staying.
What's your name and how long does it
say?
How long she was up there for?
Do they know?
Did she admit it?
She in jail.
She insists.
It's actually her house.
He knocked and found a dark haired woman
who said that Jimmy was letting him live
there.
He called the police,
but the woman who fled before they
arrived.
Wait.
It's not unusual to what and it's a go
back up a little bit.
It's not unusual.
Oh,
was it say,
but one man was shocked to find a woman.
I wonder how often that happens.
It's not unusual to find unwelcome bats,
squirrels or termites in the attic,
but one man found a woman.
Ooh,
Jesus Christ.
What does that
some other video started playing.
Here's where she was.
Wow.
Apartment there,
so she had like a little spot up there.
If you look this up too,
it's.
This isn't an uncommon story.
This happened a few times to other
people.
Oh Shit.
They're just living in their fucking
house.
Well,
there's a lot of homeless people that
eventually become squatters.
That's a big problem with people to
someone just set up shop and your house
and start living there and cooking and
bringing food home and they changed the
locks and then they say,
this is my house,
and then you have to.
You have to actually figure out some way
to prove that it's your house.
Then you didn't send it,
you know,
rent it to them or that you have to
figure out a way to kick them out,
kick their ass.
When you thought about fucking what do
you see someone living in your house,
you're going to fucking try to go to
court.
If you look,
let's say this side kick and randomly
the not maybe me,
but what if,
what if?
What if you're a guy that has a house in
big bear.
Okay,
okay.
And you're,
you're not there very often and then you
go up to big bear one day and the locks
changed and some guys looking at through
the window,
can I help you?
And you're like,
this is my house.
The fuck it is is my house.
And you're like,
what are you talking about?
Why you in my house would you do to buy
locks?
Like the guys just squatter duty.
Come back with some friends and you just
fucked.
Fuck this dude out.
He's got a gun.
You come and go.
He calls the police,
the police show up.
And the police like you breaking and
entering like,
no,
this is my house.
I know he lives here.
Possession is nine tenths of the law.
This gentleman's inside the building.
I always heard that from kids.
Possession is nine tenths of the law.
What is there a fucking percentage of
the law is the law.
The law possession is nine tenths of the
law.
Is that real?
What?
That's how it's hard to say what I would
do.
I saw something about it.
Let them have the house.
Some woman bought a house and right when
she was about to move in some woman who
had just moved in and she had been there
for like two weeks and she changed the
locks and she was like,
someone leased it to me online.
Like she said that someone online like
was leasing this lady's house.
Is it a scam or is it real?
It could be a scam on both sides.
Could be she's lying or it could be
someone ran a scam on her and got her to
pay rent for a house and she really
thought it was hers could be.
Right.
That's true.
Totally.
Was I think I was fooled what's up?
Eddie called this video out properly
being fake,
I think.
Which video?
That video of the lady in the apartment.
Oh yeah.
Fake.
I found a story.
Apparently people are adding this video
to that story.
So yeah,
this have another side.
I just said that it was a marketing
campaign for a rental website.
The Daily Mail UK put out a marketing
campaign.
I mean,
I'll show you a series of thing.
How would they use that to get business?
I said,
this video is fake.
It's a marketing campaign.
Oh,
interesting campaign for what?
We're making an apartment style.
Damn fake news,
man.
Real fake news.com.
Go Watch that shit.
That's just like Blair witch.
So much shit.
I believe Blair witch.
The first time I saw it,
I thought it was really hard.
Did you ever see the Bobcat Goldthwait
Blair witch style movie?
He made a boot and move about bigfoot
willow creek.
It's a Blair witch style bigfoot movie.
It's pretty fucking good.
If you want to get scared at the idea is
that all those people that go missing in
the forest,
that's one thing where people go
missing.
That's legit.
Like a ton of people go missing every
year in the national parks,
national parks and forests,
they just easy,
easy to pick them off their road,
get Jack if there's a market for it,
you don't think there's guys out there
trying to make money.
I think they're getting eaten by
animals.
People are there in deep woods and
they're falling down and breaking their
leg and getting eaten by bears and shit.
For sure.
There's a lot of that.
When you have someone that like if
you're in the business,
that's a good spot.
Get people camping so I'll never see it.
They're never going to investigate.
They're going to say a bear took them.
Yeah.
Your Business.
That would be.
If that was your business,
go and what's the easiest way?
Right,
but bears can't get people.
I know.
It's a poor guy that got perfect.
Good.
Just got jack the other day,
woke up and his tent to the sound of his
skull cracking because a bear with
biting down on a skull.
Oh,
the kid that got killed.
How often do every year kill people?
Every year.
Every United States.
Every year someone's getting killed.
Many five.
Couple for a couple.
Two,
three.
Not that many.
You know?
A kid got killed at rutgers and then the
most recent one,
a kid got killed.
He was in a road race in Alaska.
It was racing like some track event and
he was lagging behind and he saw a bear
and the bear was going after him and
he's like,
he called his mom and said mom was bare
following me and the bear jacked him,
dragged him into the woods.
They had to kill the bear.
The bear was like,
oh,
hoarding.
Like covering the body,
like protecting it.
Oh,
they found the bear at.
Because the mom sent someone out.
Yeah,
they found the fair.
The found the bear guarding the body.
Think it was his and he was going to eat
it.
How much they eat at that point for
whatever he could get tore him apart
though.
It's not a good way to go.
No.
How about that documentary with that
crazy dude who timothy treadwell was one
of the best documentaries ever.
Grizzly man.
The way it was setup to cause the first
half of the documentary who really liked
that guy like this guy really cares
about these bears and all the sound
bites that we're using from the multiple
interviews that they took were all stuff
that we're saying good things about them
and you're like,
oh,
and then the slow it gets dark.
It was just this crazy dude out there
who's crazier and crazier and crazier as
time goes on.
When I love.
When the pilot was it a pilot sheriff,
grizzly man Grizzly,
because it a pirate of the sheriff goes.
I thought he was retarded setting lap
though.
It's funny
with bears,
you can't be hanging out.
He wasn't just hanging out with bears.
He was hanging out with them deep into
the late season were the only ones that
were alive that weren't in hibernation
where the starving ones,
like he was in a danger zone.
Like most of the time those bears,
like if you're around bears that are
eating salmon,
you're not even in danger.
They're just eating so much salmon.
They don't want to try to chase you.
Didn't even think of you as real.
Yeah.
There's an area that we,
uh,
was it the Kenai peninsula,
that video that we showed where that
huge bear wanders up to that dude.
It's not even trying to kill him.
It doesn't even care because there's
like 30 bears on the stream and they're
all just jack and salmon.
They're eating so much salmon,
but this bear lumbers up and it's like
the size of a vw bus.
It's so fucking big and this to just sit
in there and this bears is just walks
over with these dead button eyes.
They have those black dead eyes.
Oh,
they're so creepy.
I mean,
they're beautiful in a lot of ways,
but look at this thing.
Look at this thing right up next to his
lawn chair.
Look at these things.
Eyes.
This is an eating machine.
That's what that is.
That's like a pit bull times a thousand
to thousand pounds eating machine
and they look so lovable.
Yeah,
of course.
They look like your friends in the
movies that talk.
Well,
what are you guys want to do to teddy
bears?
Should we go fusion?
A lot of fishing going on here and so
this guy's hanging out and it just
starts walking towards him.
I mean this thing is 10 feet from him
and we're eating the bear.
Yeah,
eat bear black bear.
What does it taste like?
Like fuck the cow.
Nice at this.
This thing is just to get his nails.
Look at those fucking clause.
Holy Shit.
The head on that thing.
That is an enormous bet on this guy.
This guy just freezing.
Yeah,
I mean he was taking pictures.
He's a photographer and it shows it
towards the end of the video and this
guy was taking pictures of that river
which is filled with bears filled with
bears,
eat and salmon,
and this is just a full bear.
He's full.
So he says to the bear,
hey,
look at the code.
Just noise,
just noise.
Now look at that,
look at it.
We'll
get all the bears back up real quick.
I'd want to see them look at this to do
this.
Look at this.
Look when he turns,
look at all these fucking bear.
Holy Shit.
There's so many bears.
So this area,
which is overwhelmed by bears,
there's never been a death report it
there.
They don't kill people there because
there's so many fucking salmon that they
just gorge themselves on salmon and just
chill out.
But if they're hungry they'll fuck you
up.
I just figure you out.
Like I could eat this dude.
And then once they eat you that,
well I can't believe I didn't need him
before.
That was easy.
Like it's like we have this stupid idea
that there's a contract.
We have a stupid idea.
Like there's some contract between us
and bears know they're not going to fuck
us up.
Well,
they like us.
We're cool.
Most Times bears are scared of people.
Is there a video of a bear and a lion
fighting onshore?
Right?
Probably like China or something.
If you had to put money on a full grown
bear,
grizzly bear or a lion,
what do you think?
I'm going with the lion all day.
Yeah.
I'm going to cat.
They both have tremendous clause.
Yeah.
I'm going with the cat.
He's more athletic.
He moves better cats.
Just fuck everything up.
They fuck everything up.
They fuck up.
Crocodiles.
You seen leopards?
Jack Crocodiles,
Jaguars,
Jaguars.
Greg,
Jack,
crocodiles.
I bit leopards do too.
Yeah.
They just cancerous too fast.
The two mean did the meanest of all the
animals and they're one of the rare
animals that only eats meat,
like they only killed things.
Like what do bears eat?
Berries and she got a polar bear versus
a great white shark.
I got to go with the shark.
I think the barrel fuck up.
The great white.
I don't think he's going to be able to
fuck them up in the water.
They swim and swim that good.
All right.
Not that good.
Oh,
this is a mountain lion.
A mountain lion bear.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
Them outlines,
bite in the bear in the head and the
bears like whatever.
Bitch.
Barely.
This is amazing.
I barely.
Oh,
so it's a female.
It's a male bear and a female mountain
lion that's guarding or cubs pair in the
face.
It's like,
well,
let's make a killer video.
They just take this captured mountain
lion and bear and they just,
oh,
that's ready to go at it.
I think that's real.
She's just trying to keep that therapy
for the kids because if you just have
cameras set up where a mountain lion
activity is de,
stay away,
use a zoom lens.
There's a bunch of different ways.
I mean,
they've gotten a bunch of different
really incredible encounters between
animals just by filming hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of hours.
You stay in the field for months at a
time.
You see things like,
look at this lion and the bear.
Those are some good camera angles,
so get this,
but that's a black bear.
See someone set this up.
That's a black bear and a lion.
That's crazy.
That's not a big bear.
That's a small bear and a big line
blind.
Never lived together.
Yeah.
How would.
How would they be in the same spot?
Somebody put them together.
No,
no other way.
Black lines are only in Africa.
The pairs are only in North America.
This one at least.
Actually.
Probably.
They probably got some of those in Asia
that looks similar.
That looks like a zoo right?
There.
It is.
As a.
What the fuck is that animal?
That's another one.
Those two lines.
Oh,
he's about to get some.
he's taking a shit.
There's a bear in there too.
Oh,
the bear gets lead in later.
Oh Shit.
There's a bear right there.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
What's going on here?
This is like some like a snuff film.
Well they do shit like that in like
other countries.
Yeah.
I've seen videos where they have betting
matches.
Look at this as barren.
This line is like my food.
That's a big ass black bear.
Take them,
fight over the food.
That's a thing.
And doing over there.
Just facing the eating something or
eating something.
Okay.
This is weird.
I don't understand.
It's um,
I think they're just go to back.
What about a full grown chimp versus a
tiger tiger all day.
Really?
Yeah.
I got with the cat.
You always go.
I always go with a cat.
Especially the cats.
Bigger like a full grown cat can be like
900 pounds.
Plus Hydros can swim,
right?
Yeah.
Do they go into water?
They could swim underwater.
Yeah.
Tiger versus great white.
Great Light.
You think so water.
You don't always go for cats that I
always go for cat,
but the great white,
so much bigger.
Still a cat.
There's a picture of a surprise.
I think a tiger would take a fucking.
They're taken out.
Crocodiles,
great.
White.
They're not smart.
That's true.
They try to eat cages and shit.
I don't think they'd be able to do
anything with it though.
I don't think it's too much.
It's like,
you know,
a real great whites,
like a thousand pounds.
I went to Fox.
That tiger going to do.
Then it's swim with it and its mouth.
They figured out that you could swim
with all sharks.
Now the sharks are like if it hit them
at the right time or whatever,
you could swim with sharks except for
great whites,
but there is one lady who swims of great
white sharks.
What is this?
15 foot,
what is it?
14 or 15 foot.
Great white like in three foot of water
off the coast of Mexico.
In this bay.
It got.
It got hit right here,
but the propeller,
but they found out it was feeding off
Stinger race.
It wasn't like beach journey thing.
Oh really?
Close to a dude.
It's fuck.
Where's this?
That's why I was there.
It wasn't there because it was stuck in
there because it was feeding off sting
range.
If you watched the whole video,
the guy that they're wondering if it's
like caught in a net or what's going on
with that.
He gets real close here.
You can see this.
This injury on its back.
It got hit by propeller.
I'm not going to show this online.
If you want to look it up on Youtube.
It's Pearson brothers winery films.
Fifty yanked my views on it right now.
It's A.
Yeah.
Whenever you try to put someone else's
youtube video on your youtube video,
you get yanked.
Look at the scars on his back,
so he all got.
He got fucked up by a propeller.
That's what happened.
Now it also starts moving around too.
I think I got a little fucking Harry.
Wow.
It's pretty dark.
I guess size of that thing.
I didn't know there were so dark.
Well,
it's probably just shitty lighting
or shitty.
Scary.
Scariest.
Fuck.
That looks like a great thing.
Just an eating machine.
There's been a bunch of videos that are
really crazy to watch.
Where they take a drone.
They flied over Malibu and you see these
people surfing and just a few hundred
yards outside.
People surf.
When you see a great white water.
No,
we're in Malibu.
Oh Shit.
Ooh.
Yeah.
That guy's in the water right next to
that thing.
Got Woken at it.
He got hit by a sting right twice in his
foot.
One was like a six inch gas.
He said,
oh Jesus.
So there must be like a school,
a stingray singly jacked his foot.
Oh fuck man.
What are you doing?
We retarded.
Get out of their kid.
Fucked up.
Step it on sting rays.
You fuck like you accidentally step on
them,
right?
Don't they like bury themselves in the
sand?
Is there video of that?
Drove Filming Malibu?
Yeah.
Pull.
Uh,
pull up a great white spotted off of
southern California coast.
Look at that now.
This is Malibu?
Yes.
Pismo beach.
It says.
Okay.
That's pretty close.
That's a couple hours up the coast.
There's a gang of them.
And are they great white sharks there?
Yeah,
they think it's a great white when they
get real big,
there's a,
there's a quite a few videos that
they're catching drones.
One of them,
they had people real recently.
They evacuated the beach.
Sad.
Oh Shit.
Oh fuck the wave.
It's right there.
It's right there with everybody.
You know what?
They should have those patrolling the
beach.
The other one right now.
He has no idea.
Isn't that crazy?
It's right there.
Oh fuck.
He's just waiting.
Wave.
And that is right underneath them.
Are you kidding me?
Fuck all that.
He has no idea.
And what does that thing?
And then he's gone.
He's gone a bit of a bitch.
You sharks all the time.
They were about to go on some surfer and
then they take a fucking wave and he
saved his ass.
Do they probably are near death often.
Those guys are so gangster guys like
Kelly slater and.
Yeah,
fuck that.
Dorian job's fucked it up for me,
man.
Joe.
I know that's brainwashed.
All that.
But it worked.
I was brainwashed as a movie.
This
was about,
you know,
when it was a,
what the inspiration was some real
shark.
That was real shark attack in
freshwater.
It's real crazy.
There's a,
there's a shark,
a bull shark that swims from the ocean
up rivers into fresh water and can get
as far north as Illinois and then the
most aggressive sharks day and they
killed a bunch of people in a river in
New Jersey.
Yeah,
I think it was like the early 19
hundreds,
I want to say like the 19 thirties or
some shit.
They killed a bunch of people in our
fresh water river in New Jersey,
so these people would be swimming.
Hey,
let's go swimming.
All right.
Everybody,
and they didn't know shit back then and
then just see.
Just just get torn apart by sharks.
I think it had happened.
Uh,
where's that one?
Indiana side of the Ohio River,
the Indiana side of the Ohio River.
And they catch a fucking bull shark.
Do you?
Not Crazy.
That is that thing.
Got All the way up the river in fresh
water.
They're the only shark that we know that
can do that.
And Weird.
Weirdly,
it's one of the most aggressive sharks.
I don't think we know of any other
sharks that go up.
Fresh water like that.
Right?
It's not the only one.
I think that's the only one to travel up
rivers.
They have been known to travel as far up
as Indiana in the Ohio River.
Although I've been recorded attacks,
they're probably responsible for the
majority of nearshore shark attacks,
including many attacks attributed to
other sharks and see if he could find
the inspiration for the movie jaws,
Shark attacks in New Jersey.
Because it was all in fresh water.
That's what's fucked up about it.
It wasn't even like the movie jaws where
it was actually in the ocean.
Like these people had no idea that.
No idea.
Nineteen 16.
Imagine all that.
People were like babies back then.
They didn't know shit.
They just landed on the coast of
America.
Nineteen 16.
How long you've been there?
You know?
17,
76 to 1916.
People just got their no airplane there.
A hundred years.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Like thanked 1916 in 2017 when you can
sit back and think about it.
Nineteen 16 was essentially a 100 years
ago.
One hundred one years ago and just a
hundred years before that you got 18,
1600 years before that you got 17.
16.
So it's like the beginning of the
country still hunt couple of hundred
years into the beginning of the country
and that was just 100 years ago.
Great.
White Shark attack.
Five people near the Jersey shore.
Huh?
This is a different story.
Unless they called it a great white
shark and it was a bull shark.
Is that.
I think that's different.
I think that's a different story.
There was a bunch of attacks on a river
in New Jersey in the early 19 hundreds.
I don't think that's the one.
I think that's a different one.
There's obviously been a bunch of
attacks spring lake and into twin creek
zen.
It rode great white.
But uh,
but the one that's a great wide.
Huh?
That's different.
I thought it was a bull shark.
That's just what this says.
Hmm.
What's,
when's the story from the stores?
Is Nineteen Sixteen,
2012.
Well,
if it's in the Smithsonian,
you gotta think that's probably right.
I could've swore it was bull sharks
though.
And it killed more than one person
either way.
Fuck sharks,
right?
Yeah.
I don't fuck with the ocean.
Do you go fishing?
No,
no,
I didn't do it.
Now I'll probably get into it for my
son.
I'll probably get into it.
He likes it,
but I ain't trying to go way out in the
ocean.
I have no desire and it goes.
I like watching it on dvds and shit the
deep.
And you know that the deepest part of
the ocean,
like,
I forget what it's called,
James Cameron,
where he goes down that submarine.
There's like A.
There's like a trench.
Yes.
I like shit like that.
There's a lot of mysterious shit that
goes on there.
Do you know where the best place to go?
Shark fishing in the world is South
Africa right off.
Catalina really did.
It's one of the best in the world.
They catch these giant Maaco sharks and
they taste good.
You can eat them for those people get
mad at you though.
That's a new thing.
People get mad if you.
If you eat sharks,
if you kill sharks,
he will get mad.
Yeah,
they shouldn't be mad at that.
But they,
they don't get mad if you killed like a
tuna.
Tuna's okay.
But sharks are bad because people have
been brainwashed into thinking that
people eat shark fin soup and they waste
the shark.
So then people start thinking of shark
fishing.
Like they think of trophy hunting.
I think of like killing lions or
something like that.
You're just killing it for no reason.
You're not eating it like they don't
realize they go shop for food you like,
nobody does a Japanese do now they just
kill them.
They kill them because they're getting
in the way of their tune and production
to the trailing the eight and they make
Dolphin Burger's really?
Yep.
Ooh,
seems wrong.
They trap them in a cove and just
fucking Harpoon into math.
When they were doing that,
they were just killing them because they
were getting in the way of their tune.
That only shit.
They're not going to just waste that.
That set.
Have you watched?
I've seen a documentary.
It could be bullshit,
but seem legit,
but isn't it weird?
It feels weird,
right?
Like eating a,
eating a dolphin seems fucked up.
The Japanese,
like they were totally into killing
whales all the time.
Or do they still do whaling?
Yeah,
that's pretty fucked up.
Right?
Definitely.
They use it for all kinds of stuff,
right.
They would eat the whale blubber,
you know,
one of the things they do now,
they,
um,
they should kill whales under the false
pretense of a.
they're trying to do scientific research
that allowed to do some scientific
research on whales,
so they kill a few whales and then they
take those whales,
they kill and they sell whatever parts.
Smart gangster.
The illuminati.
I'd be like green,
like that shit.
That's a good one.
I think it's a little monotony.
I think it's a Japanese fishing market
that's always been doing that.
They've been selling and buying and
killing whales forever,
and so then when these new environmental
standards got raised,
they said,
oh yeah,
well we have to do a little research you
to do a little research.
Perfect.
Those that company or that group,
the sea shepherds,
do you know who they are?
They're the ones who bust people who
were wailing in illegal whaling because
otherwise you gotta think you find some
whaling boat in the middle of the
fucking ocean.
Think I begged the goddamn ocean is
there's a boat out there somewhere in
the middle of it that's whaling.
How are you going to find them?
What are you gonna?
Do they go out there and ram these boats
and they'd shoot like air guns or
something like that?
Don't like water,
water,
guns.
They do a bunch of shit to try to
disrupt it and then they try to expose.
Isn't there a TV show about it?
Think so.
Whale warriors or some point.
They shouldn't be fucking with whales
and dolphins.
Yeah,
they're too smart and I was okay.
Cows.
Okay.
Chickens or cows or dom.
Hey chicken.
Not that gum.
Have you seen those videos of the cows
that they kind of loose?
Yeah,
they get.
We're in a slaughterhouse.
They send them like they're smarter than
we think.
What about octopus?
Also?
Definitely happy.
And you go to some restaurants and you
can eat a live octopus.
He just boil them.
That's fucked up.
Tying restaurant.
They had it on the menu last night.
Grilled Octopus of how we've talked
about it on the podcast.
They're smart as fuck.
They are smart as fuck,
but you know,
look at that.
They're smart.
It's going to go through a whole lot of
tiny little tiny asshole.
Right?
Where's the hole?
The hole in the wall.
I got obsessed with octopus videos for
law.
I want more.
I want,
I want.
They've got a poor fuck NASA and
$18,000,000,000
put some more money into octopuses
octopuses dolphins,
monkeys.
Whereas that thing going out the boat.
Whoa.
Is going through that hole in the wall.
Yep.
Right out the side of the boat.
Why I get that shit.
That's an alien life form.
I mean I might as well be from another
planet.
Yeah.
Have you found that on another planet?
You'd be so excited.
She the one that guy released it into
the water and it like came up and it
said it came up to thank him.
Look at that shit.
It's hard to tell if that was piling out
of that crack too slowly.
That head com impressing itself had the
brand and everything that has to worry
about is the beak.
I don't think they have like a classic
brain like we think of.
Look at that.
That's nuts.
Through a little tiny hole right at the
end of it.
Scoop it up with a net psych.
He tried too hard,
but I saw a common bitch.
It's crazy.
Eat Octopus.
Yeah.
Damn.
I think dad does too.
I don't think there's some octopus
attack.
Yeah,
I don't think they're nice north.
I think Canada,
they're worried that were assholes and
they're probably right,
but I don't think there's a lot of
morals going on the octopus community.
Do you ever see that one video of
octopuses that were taken out?
Sharks in an aquarium.
They had this big ass aquarium.
They kept missing sharks.
They're like,
what the fuck is going on?
Like someone's killing our sharks and
then they put a video.
They set it up and I found that the
octopus always get busted with cameras.
Right.
There's so many hidden camera videos
like pet octopuses getting out of their
aquarium.
Oh yeah.
And going into another aquarium,
a jack in the fish and then climbing
back in.
Look at this.
Do they attack each other as attack each
other?
That's a very good question.
Octopus wars.
I'm sure they have them.
Right.
Look how he fucks.
This shark doesn't have a chance.
It's a tiny shark.
It is a baby.
It's like a toddler still doesn't have a
chance.
Do you know that they feel like they're
pretty sure that they found fossil
evidence of enormous suction cups,
which would indicate that at one point
in time there was a thing like a
cracking,
like an enormous hundred foot long
octopus.
I believe that the private I'd probably
still exists probably.
Right?
We don't know shit about the ocean.
Will you see those giant squids right
here?
She knows.
Yeah.
You ever seen that one?
They found when they had one of those
offshore,
uh,
offshore oil,
things.
One of those things.
Do they have it on Youtube?
Giant squid.
What's that?
Offshore oil rig.
Alien Squid or the biggest,
the biggest squid.
They found this fucking square.
That one.
They didn't
even know this thing existed until they
had a camera set up and look at that
fucking thing.
It's got like crab legs.
They found this enormous giant squid in
the ocean.
They didn't even know it existed until
they got this video look.
A pig.
That shit.
It's huge.
It's like it has like a mom's like,
go back to that image Jamie and freeze
on it.
Like it's hard to tell.
We did something like a boat next to it
or it's hard to tell how big it is.
Well,
they've caught them.
They've caught giant squid now.
The giant squid used to be like a rumor.
They used to find dead ones
occasionally,
but now that's thrown them and caught
them.
Yeah,
it's huge man.
What it looks like an alien.
Like that thing looks like an alien.
Like liquid is like crab,
like legs where it bends.
I want to how smart pr they should do.
Some experiments.
Some giant squids.
Maybe they're just stupid.
Octopus are smart and they're just good
for Sushi there.
Make a hell of a Sushi.
Tell you that.
I liked squid Sushi like it.
You don't like Sushi?
I don't like seafood at all.
I like to.
I like canned tuna.
Sardines no fucking way.
I said Shit.
Ever Oysters?
Hell no,
but I do like.
I do like black cod or is it black cod
gets from the east.
It's like racist.
I see what it says.
I don't like.
White is black cod.
They serve.
It tastes like candy.
I like that.
So I know what you're talking about.
You're talking about like me,
so cod.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's me.
So I think it's called black cod.
Yeah,
black cod with like a miso dressing.
So a lot of Asian restaurants here.
I love that.
It tastes fishy.
Like Salmon.
I don't like that shit.
Trout a really not into.
I don't know man.
You met under very different taste.
I wish I wasn't do it.
God Damn you don't even.
She sounds so much fun.
Like what am I showing?
Gives me organ meat.
Liver.
So good for you.
I want shit that doesn't remind me that
it's used to be an animal living.
No desire.
That's why like Mcdonald's,
because I know that shit ain't meet
eventually,
but if you were on a farm,
have you are on a farm and the only way
to eat you had to shoot a cow and
butcher it and grind it up.
How would you handle that?
Because you do it.
I'd get used to it.
You get used to it.
I'm sure I would.
If I had to eat.
I was starving.
You Go Vegan or would you just kill the
cows?
What was the choice again?
Go Vegan.
I'm going to get all your food from the
farm I got to get.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let's say if like we're in some,
like a day of the dead fucking.
I'd had chicken night of the living dead
chickens walking dead Zombie scenario to
kill chickens.
Chickens.
No problem.
Um,
you wouldn't kill God.
Put chickens on the planet for us.
I think animals eat other animals,
right?
It's true.
That's what we do every day with
deciding sleep chickens out there for
the people.
Man.
I can't believe the dogs.
And then like,
Oh shit,
what the fuck?
Chinese people.
You have a festival
which is eating dogs.
How about the Indians think I.
cows are sacred and we.
And they must think we're fucking crazy.
Well,
certain parts of India,
right?
What does that,
is it just the Hindus?
The think that I think most India.
What do you think that's from?
Just culture.
Mushrooms maybe for sure.
Oh,
that's right.
For sure.
So this grows out of cow shit.
It only grows out of cows.
Jet Predominantly.
Really?
Yeah.
Dan,
we can find it in field to get a couple
of cows.
Chickens,
Shit,
dude,
are you kidding?
You make your own mushrooms.
You can get your own mushrooms.
Mushrooms.
That's right.
All easy to guess.
You buy kits,
you know?
What do you mean your closet.
You know that conspiracy theory that,
that Mcdonald's doesn't actually use
real meat,
you know,
some people call it,
but some people believe it and it's easy
to believe eventually it's gonna come
out that they're not.
They're using some other kind of Shit
fillers or whatever that it's already
admit they use some sort of filler.
Yeah,
but they're not.
They're not admitting that they're not
using meat.
That Mcdonald's has never said.
We don't use meat.
Hold on.
What the mcrib what do they say?
That same compound that they say is
using yoga mats or something that fake
rubber come,
come on,
but they're not.
Mcdonald's is not out there saying,
hey,
we don't use real meat.
They're saying 100 percent beef.
Dude.
I just got commercials.
Yeah,
but they don't say that for about the a
day saying $100,
but here's a conspiracy theory is that
hundred per 100 percent beef is actually
just the name.
It's a trademark.
Oh,
that's right.
I don't know if that's real.
I read that.
So when they say 100 percent beef,
that's just the name of the company that
makes the beat.
I read that.
That was,
that's the ultimate mind.
Fuck right there,
right.
You know what they do?
All they need to do is little by little.
Say Yes.
We don't use.
We don't use first.
They have a,
a,
a fake meat Vegan Burger.
Yes.
Fake me and slowly tell people inch by
inch that.
Oh yeah.
We don't use real mean brill.
Meat's bad for you.
It causes cancer.
Why would we're we're helping you.
We're trying to save you.
If you don't want to eat meat.
I feel like that was shut down.
I think 100 percent real beef was like
shut down like that.
They were trying to make a product
called 100 percent real beef.
What a sneaky fucking loophole.
What kind of shocked.
Yeah,
no I'm not,
but what kind of a monster would do that
create a fake meat and call it a 100
percent real beef and that was the name
of the meat,
like you know,
what's your dog's name?
Oh,
my dog's name is 100 percent real beef.
Like just naming it right?
You just make it a name.
That's so fucking sneaky.
Is that true?
I don't know.
It could be a.
It could be a myth.
It's not true.
Jamie,
same listeners into subway,
Newsweek,
McDonald's,
Mcdonald's.
Try to copyright the term 100 percent
real beef and use it on,
on Patty's that weren't just all beef.
I think they did.
I feel like someone did that.
I don't know if it was Mcdonald's,
but I feel like you're right.
I feel surprised if it's true,
but it could be a hoax.
I remember it.
You know,
it's hard to tell what's real these
days.
We can look on snopes,
but nobody trusts them anymore.
It was false,
but I won't.
I'll find another source.
What a snopes.
Can't trust false.
What do they say about what's.
What's caused the rumor mill?
Snopes is and what's false?
They're saying,
don't do this,
don't do it.
Don't do it.
You can wait.
You're hungry or you train it again.
How's your back?
My knees fucked up.
It popped out again.
Saturday I did a seminar in oceanside,
10 panadols and strategy side and it
fucking popped out again.
I was on the floor and then this time I
was like,
I can't squat down for a long time
because I was squatting down giving Kyle
bame a brown belt out there.
He's,
he's a bad ass grappler.
I was just giving him some hot rubber
guard advice while I was squatting on
the balls of my feet and you're on the
balls of your feet and it blew out there
and I went.
When I stood up,
that's how blood originally and when I
stood up the thing popped out and I'm
like,
Oh shit.
Coming in.
I was in serious pain and then I
straighten up my leg and it popped back
in.
Man,
I'm going to need surgery because the
doctor said for six weeks because that
happened six weeks ago and the doctor
said,
make sure you don't do anything stupid
on it for the next six weeks because if
it pops out again,
my acl was hanging on by a thread.
It's probably all gone now.
That's probably all gone.
My knees fucked up so I'm going to need
surgery.
I'm just going to do it,
but meanwhile I'm just going to lift
hard.
I'm just gonna.
Make sure while my knees recovering my
upper body as strong as hell.
Dr Mcgee,
Dr Rodney Mcgee.
Yeah,
I talked to him.
He didn't have a new way of attaching
the acl where they don't have to give
you a cadaver graft anymore.
When did you talk to them?
Uh,
before it popped out again.
So I need to talk to them again.
This is what they're doing now.
They're,
they're changing the recovery times
drastically because the old way,
what they do is they take a cadaver
graft,
right?
So they'd take a piece out of a dead guy
or they'd take your hamstrings,
Patella the Patella.
Don and I had to get the advert done.
What's better?
You think the cadaver but the cadaver it
can get infected and then it gets real.
I've never heard of that APP.
That's a problem.
I haven't had it happen to me.
Mine was.
Mine went super smooth.
I did all my rehab.
I did a good job of the Rehab.
I was.
DABBING is good.
It's great.
My cadaver knee doesn't bother me even a
little.
You had acl?
Both directions.
Both.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
And you see what I can do.
My legs.
What year?
[inaudible] 94 with the Patella tendon
graft.
Two thousand three with the uh,
acl with the counselor when I got.
That was when I got my biggest when I'm
was the first one was done with the
Patella graphs that a hamstring?
No.
And then the second one in 2003 was
done.
Cadaver Cadaver?
Yeah.
In both knees are good.
Oh yeah.
They don't pop out?
No.
Did it pop out?
Is that how it ripped before slid out
it?
Well,
the first one felt um,
I,
I tore it kicking the bag.
I was tired and I was doing rounds on
the bag and I threw a kick and my leg
was planted and it didn't.
My foot didn't pivot.
I was just doing rounds,
was real tired.
I was trying to put it out exactly.
And I was 21 and I think I'd heard it
before then I just didn't realize how
bad I'd heard it.
And then I heard it again.
It popped like I felt it explode in the
gym and then I went to the hospital and
they checked it out and the whole deal.
And,
and uh,
I've eventually got it fixed.
And then the other one.
No,
you know what?
I heard it a couple different ways.
But Anyway,
point is it,
it blew out.
Um,
my second one that I got done,
it was introduced to class.
I was in half guard,
I was on top and someone had the lock
down sideways.
So instead of straightening me out
normal,
like,
you know where your leg bends and
extends it hyper extends,
it went this way,
like against the side of the knee.
And it just was a weird angle and he
straightened his leg out and it just
popped up.
You can hear it snap like a carrot snap.
And I didn't even know it was broken.
I thought it was just really painful.
And then the next day I was actually
walking around.
Okay.
And I didn't think anything was wrong.
I thought it was just really sore.
And then I was moving some stuff around
in my office and it just went.
It just fell out of the socket.
Slipped out,
gave out?
Yeah.
Just gave out.
And I knew that feeling before because
of my other knee.
And then did you have to straighten it
out and pop it back in?
No,
it didn't.
That wasn't a problem because it wasn't.
There was no meniscus tear on the right
one.
The left one had meniscus tear as well.
Remember?
One time I blew that out in class and I
was like,
my leg locked.
Do you remember that?
And you had to drive my car.
Forget that he drove me to the doctor
and driving your Nsx,
a stick shift.
And I was grinding the gears.
Your knee was tore apart.
You were like,
you're fucking piss driving,
you know,
because your knee and I'm fucking up
your car and you're like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Don't you go to fucking driver's stick?
I'm like,
dude,
I haven't driven a stick and forever
it's sticks.
Sticks to the easel about automatics,
baby.
It's 2017 and people would still got
sticks.
What the fuck is going on?
All my cars and.
Come on man.
I love sticks.
I supposed to text.
I don't know.
I'm kidding.
That's not a good job.
Yo.
Get in.
Wrecks.
Protects stage.
Do.
Yeah.
How many people have been in wrecks
while they're facetiming?
I saw some good face time and on the
highway.
I've seen a couple people do it.
Facetime and while they're driving him,
I'm gonna.
Give you that sweet Dick Mama Way.
Yeah.
That's incredible.
I love driving stick shifts though.
I prefer it.
I don't like it.
Maybe you would like it if you drove a
sports car.
Why don't you get one of those engines
that you crank like in 1910 and you
liked that you control the anymore.
If they made them,
you would get them maybe what have you
had to start your car by cranking?
Yeah,
but you don't feel like there's some fun
and shifting the gears.
I know what it was like,
you know,
what it was,
is my first car was a 1977 pinto station
wagon and I got it for $550 and it was a
stick shift.
I always wanted,
uh,
the cheaper cars were always stick
shift.
I could only afford to stick shift.
The more expensive cars had the
automatic.
And I guess it was just,
I was
brainwashed into thinking,
fuck,
one of these days I'm going to be able
to drive an automatic fuck this bag.
You will bullshit.
And I think it was just a mind fuck.
So once I was,
once I got my first automatic car,
Mike Fox stick shift,
you could just,
I had a bunch of automatics and then I
got a stick shift.
I had a bunch of muscle cars and then I
got an Audi.
Fox is a tiny little Audi car.
It was a little front wheel drive car
and it was a stick shift.
It was like a zippy little car like me.
I loved it.
I was like,
Ooh,
I love like shifting the gears,
but it wasn't until I got my first NSX,
Nsx,
Nsx in 95 or six,
maybe 97,
97 and then I had another one that I got
in like 2004.
It was a bad ass car.
Love those things.
They're so different now.
Now the new NSX is like this big
technological spaceship thing.
I like it.
It's dope.
It's going.
I don't think so,
but it's a different thing.
I liked.
I liked the little cars that you can.
You're,
you're in control of like a,
like A.
I don't like the big electronic car.
That's why I like the Porsche because
that thing's light.
It's light and you control everything.
You feel it.
You feel the road like,
like if you're in a sports car for me,
like a fast car,
you want to feel everything.
Makes it exciting.
You don't get any of that Shit,
I dunno.
Maybe don't even like liver or was that.
You don't even like liver.
Like you and I are very different.
Oh No,
no,
I didn't let you sliced hearts.
There is an Nsx that looks incredible
leadership.
It's already out.
Oh yeah.
Not only is an out.
They just released an Nsx gt three,
so if you want to race,
if you want to be a racecar driver,
they'll sell you one of those and it
costs a half a million bucks.
Holy Shit.
It's a beast of a car man.
And the thing is,
it's a Honda.
I'm going to call it an Acura,
but it's a Honda,
which means is this not going to break?
You could drive that thing forever.
Those things will have unbelievable
reliability as opposed to like say a car
that my ancestors made.
You know,
you get something Italian,
good luck.
But is it really Japanese?
If they're making it in Mexico as they
megan that Mexico,
don't they make Honda's in Mexico?
Toyota's.
That's what I thought.
Then.
I know they make some of them in
America.
They make nissans and that's even worse.
Really.
That's a good question.
Right?
Is it considered.
Now we're talking about breaking down.
There's a awesome American cars,
but yeah,
but if they just use standards developed
by the Japanese and once they have
standards developed by the Japanese,
like what does it say?
I'm making them in Ohio,
Ohio.
Oh,
that's right.
The NSX is being made in Ohio.
That's right.
I forgot about that.
Is that good or bad?
Was real good for Americans in Ohio.
We want a good job making sex as far as
a reliability.
You know what?
Everything's automated now.
See that's the thing.
It's not like you're.
You're dealing with skilled craftsman.
You're dealing with programmers and
shit,
but like assembly line should have some.
There's some.
That was the thing about the corvette
factory in Bowling Green,
Kentucky.
Like those people,
they've put together those corvettes by
themselves.
Like there's a lot that's going on
that's a animated automated rather.
But there's a lot that's going on by
hand to get this shit.
This is crazy.
They're making cars.
So what is this guy doing right here
with this thing?
The factory,
I don't know,
I just kind of skipped ahead.
Yeah.
What's happening here?
It's hard to tell what it is.
They're flipping the thing upside down.
Oh,
they're working on the chassis.
This is the bottom of the car.
These things are just what they are now.
That's what the car looks like on the
inside before they put the seats in the
drive train and all that stuff,
but with these things are now it's all
done by these robots.
Someone controlling it real time or is
it on a program?
It's a good question.
I would bet it's probably on a program.
There's probably someone controlling it,
but they're probably just pressing start
it.
Probably lock it into place and this
thing,
I mean the way it's stacking everything,
hold on.
Some of the things that they're doing
now though mean these cars are so
precise.
They're so different than anything that
existed like 20,
30 years ago.
Like this car,
it might not be like the most,
the fastest,
best engineered cars in the world,
but it's one of them and it's just that
the horsepower wars are so out of
control right now that a car like this
is almost kind of overlooked because
there's so many insane high performance
cars now.
I mean there's so many that are zero to
60 in three seconds.
What they're doing now is just making
these unbelievable spaceships that are
regular person could buy.
If you have the money.
You don't have to be a race car driver.
You don't have to be like super
qualified to handle this thing.
You could just get a car that's 600
horsepower,
four wheel drive drives like a demon.
I mean you could just go out and buy it.
The Tesla,
the model three,
it's like 35 grand,
right?
Crazy.
Yeah.
You're buying a model three,
oh,
you're buying a fucking spaceship.
Like everything is automated.
This guy's a using torque wrenches that
everything's all set to the exact amount
you're supposed to crank.
Things like everything is.
Nothing is left to the imagination.
You know?
It's cool to make like an old classics,
like a new version,
like the charger and all that.
Yeah,
yeah.
Do model t's in a new version.
They,
those things are so like ergonomically
clumsy and so poorly designed in terms
of like aerodynamics and shit.
If you try to take a model t on the
highway,
that shit would just fall over.
Like once you got to like add,
make it right though.
But the wind resistance,
you get to like 80.
You're not trying to go fast.
It's just like a,
like a Harley.
Oh,
like a cruiser,
right?
Yeah.
Maybe.
I mean they,
they go,
they had those cruisers that,
those fifties type cars.
Right?
Like dragster things.
What are they called?
Pt cruisers.
Oh yeah.
That thing,
that thing was,
I drove one of those ones there were so
bad.
It was like you guys just made a cool
outside and through the shittiest
suspension you could.
It was so bad,
like every time I go around a corner the
ass and would like kick out and I took
it on a dirt road and I was like,
I could fly off the side of this road
and not being able to control this piece
of shit.
Right.
Oh,
those were pretty dope.
That was the PR plymoth prowler.
Is that like based on like a fifties
style car?
Sort of.
That was created by chip foose.
He's the guy that did the design element
of my 1970 Barracuda who's a wizard car
designer guy.
He invented a bunch of different cool
cars.
They had that thing that plymoth prowler
and there was another one that was kinda
like that too,
wasn't there.
It was in another one of those fucking
retro looking things.
Either you don't have kids.
If you have a car like that or you're a
shitty father,
that's your weekend car.
What?
Take my weekend car and driving around
the neighborhood.
See your super rich and you can do that
every now and then you put it in your
side garage.
That's the thunderbird.
I think foose was involved in that too,
guys.
Goddamn car wizard.
Yeah.
That's a nice one.
Is that a falcon?
No,
that's a t bird.
That's a.
that's a thunderbird,
but it has a roof on it.
Have they made newer versions of
Falcons?
Hm.
I don't think so.
Was the last time at mit a falcon in the
sixties?
Look at that thing above.
It was that.
Does that,
that movie from that movie?
Christine,
that one on the right.
The second one on the right.
The Red One?
Yeah.
Look at that.
What about cars like they should make?
No,
that's a thunder road.
Look at that thing.
God.
What about new cars like that?
Like those look like the limousine that
JFK was in.
Right?
Just a little shorter.
That's a thunderbird.
Look how bad ass that is.
That's like if you roll around on that
and Hollywood like if you're some sort
of Rockstar type character and you got a
Goddamn and you're like,
look at me,
motherfucker,
look at this shit.
Look at my white walls.
Look at that thing and that is a slick
ride.
Go back to that last one jamie.
That is a slick looking car man.
What year is that?
It's a for Thunderbird,
right?
Second Generation.
That means if I had to guess,
I'd say that's like 1960 something.
Right.
Crazy looking cars.
Like they figured it out.
They back then man,
they had just caught a design groove and
figured out how to make these really
exotic looking sexy shapes.
Fifty nine.
Wow.
Amazing.
What a car.
There's a lot of remixes possible here
for Florida and are wondering should
they do that or should they?
They did that two charges and it was a
huge grand slam.
Have you seen the new m four that got
now the Ford Gt,
the new Ford Gt.
Jesus Christ Ford's came out with a car
that's like a Super Ferrari looking car.
Let me say it.
I think it's like $300,000
for that thing.
Yup.
That's a Ford.
Come on.
Holy Shit.
It's about God damn time.
They could have did that a long time
ago.
I get that thing.
They should have did that 20 years ago.
That's.
See,
that's like whatever the NSX is,
450,
$3,000.
You need to get one of those.
Oh,
come on.
It's not even a standard.
You got an automatic transmission and
shit.
The old ones,
these dev stick to old for the dad.
What the hell?
That's the only 3 million bucks.
It's gold plated.
One driving down sunset.
Why not?
If I had one of those I never played and
I would have like three d videos of my
dick that like play all over the car.
It's like you're.
You're a hard dick.
Is like a Hologram on led screens that
are all over the car.
Do,
do,
do.
Imagine if a dude drove down the street
and he had a Bugatti with like the
outside of the car was a screen.
What did they make?
Only one dick was a $3 million.
It's got 1500 horsepower.
It's a status symbol.
It's one of those things where people
want to show everybody that they don't
even give a fuck.
They drive around a $3,000,000
car,
whether it's got a gang of them,
but ace hood has a song called I will go
bed and I woke up and I saw one drive
down by the comedy store once and
everybody looked,
oh,
that's a million dollars.
That's a million dollars.
It used to be a million.
Now the three used to be.
That was for the first million dollar
car,
so a million dollar car.
Look at this.
My book is for sale for 4 million for
that neighborhood.
That's fully.
Meanwhile,
money made,
whether it's in the dupont registry,
he's selling it for fucking 4 million.
You want to be a baller.
Want to drive around and floyd
mayweather.
He does that often.
He flips cars.
Are you kidding me?
Money buy a for to sell it for,
for not only that,
it's a good movement.
It's a smart move,
right?
Cars.
Are you kidding with social media?
He says he's his own corporation.
Yeah,
no,
it's a smart move.
What's that?
He's pissed over low ball bids.
That is Bugatti auction in his face.
He's a man.
One point five,
one point $9,000,000
bid,
because the number was still much lower
than floyd was hoping to get.
I wonder what he paid for.
It didn't sell.
Somebody offered one point $9 million.
He's like not enough.
Whoa.
Reportedly paid three point $5 million.
Oh my goodness.
So it was reported he was expecting to
make a profit and someone tried to short
them.
The same one.
Now this is the white one.
The one we just saw was the black one.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
The only people that could afford that
or people don't give a shit about that.
Well,
I think floyd is just.
His whole thing is about just being the
oldest baller guys,
guys,
guys that are in the memorabilia there
usually broke.
They don't have that much money.
Come on.
That's not a memorabilia thing.
One hundred people on the planet could
have,
could afford to do that.
You know what I mean?
And they're not impressed by having
someone celebrity.
You know what I mean?
They are.
It's more than 100 millionaire.
A billionaire is going to be going to be
treated that it's a floyd mayweather,
his car,
but it's obvious that it's flipping it
like they're too smart for that shit,
but if they wanted to get it and drive
around and let everybody know in 2013 it
says they sold their 400th day.
Ron Jesus.
So 400 people have bought go out of 400.
Over a million dollars.
Jesus,
that's a lot of money.
Four hundred million dollars at cars.
I wonder what it costs to actually make.
What do you think?
50 Bucks and it cost like $20,000
in my house.
Okay,
let's get this.
I bet this a website that shows how much
does it actually cost to build a
Bugatti?
I want to say $300,000.
I'm going to say
because it's so expensive that the
people making it will charge more.
You know what I mean?
Because it's probably going to be
$300,000.
Oh,
you agree with me?
What did you say?
I said $300.
Wait a minute.
Oh,
I ripped.
Perfect.
Well,
we'll see if we're right.
We'll see if for both.
Right?
I think that's a reasonable reasonable
thing to imply.
For Volkswagen loses six point two $5
million on each one.
They sell what Volkswagen loses.
What?
Wait a minute.
They lose 6 million when they sell it
for 3 million,
so it costs $9.
Million to make.
I'm looking.
There are lying now.
There's never.
You would never know.
I'm going over to Eddie Bravo side on
this one.
Tower.
This tower seven.
No bullshit.
Call Me Illuminati.
Illuminati.
Slamming this guy with a friend of mine
was illuminating.
Do people get tired of talking
conspiracy theories with you?
Do they get tired?
No.
They always want to bring it up and hide
it.
Usually a good thing to talk about,
a good way for a young guy to approach
you.
Hey Eddie,
I'm with you on Tarceva.
I'm with you with the flat earth,
Bro.
Hey Bro.
Check it out.
Lights you see?
Pretty freaked me to the guy a guy came
up to me with is like 12 year old
daughter and they were all like that all
into flat earth.
Twelve year olds and I go,
do you talk about flat earth at school?
She goes,
now they all think I'm crazy.
When I wanted to just give her the
benefit of the doubt into it.
Hey,
is it really that much money?
Here's the other cars that sit there in
a 17 year low with European cars.
Well,
there's lots of the last makers.
There's the biggest one.
It says smart cars.
Those are pieces of shit.
It's quite different vehicle $4,000
because of the economy.
They could be going into like the
development costs and like all the money
that had to spend testing everything
fucked right now.
Right.
Vw is fuck because they got caught
lying.
I think I caught lying about a fuel
emissions or.
Yeah,
about uh,
the fuel mileage of their
cars.
And it's also about the missions now.
Apparently they'd just been lying about
that shit for a long time.
Stuff like who's telling the truth
anywhere.
Like when it hit that level at the super
crazy high level,
they try to sell cars to.
They're like,
how do we sell these cars?
People don't give a shit.
Just tell them whatever study,
say you know,
science report,
say just whatever you have any desire to
drive around in some ball car.
Fuck yeah.
I'm not though.
I have like one,
one,
$500,
million of the money you have.
I don't,
I'm,
I'm not.
I'm driving a Tundra Tundra.
Good fucking car.
I like it.
Those get Toyota trucks.
I got it from my favorite shit for my
baby.
I'm like,
you know,
I had a beemer before that and I'm like,
I'm not going to put a baby seat in the
beamer.
I'm loaded tank.
Say about the biggest Tundra with the
biggest cab.
The biggest one I could find.
Put that baby seat right in the middle.
So He's been,
thing happens.
God forbid he's gonna make it.
You know what else they do if you're,
if you're into this,
they make side sliders on those cars
there.
They actually act as a side impact.
Protection in what?
What do you call rock slider.
So they,
uh,
they'll raise the car up a few inches
and put these rock sliders on the side
of these cars.
They do it a lot with land cruisers and
they offer significant side impact
protection.
I need to met what cars have that.
What cars were the,
the,
the best when it comes to accidents.
Accidents.
I would say like a dodge.
Ram.
Volvo is like known for that,
right?
Are they still number one,
they're known for being like real safe
and accident?
Yeah.
Maybe somebody hitting you or are they
still.
Do they still make the strongest frames?
Because basically that's what it comes
down to.
Who's making the strongest frame?
Right.
Not just that.
It's also like how the body responds to
impact,
how it,
how it crumples,
uh,
how it's engineered delivers the best.
I'm going to get that.
That's my next car.
I saw this car accident the other day.
What does that Chevy volt one.
No way number one.
Top rated number one?
Yup.
What?
As far as,
as far as the accident crash test
results?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy.
What about,
but what about them?
I would say it would have to be like a
ram or a Chevy Silverado.
It's got to be though,
because that's what they specialize in.
That's their shit.
Yeah,
but they're not as big like if you get.
Is that number one for suv?
What about for the number one truck?
What's number one?
Is that number one?
What is it?
What does it say?
I'm going to get it.
10 safest Audi.
Audi.
Goddamn.
Pop Up ads like Audi right there,
right?
What is that one?
That's the Audi shoot.
Something cute.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Q seven.
That's pretty cool car.
I've seen one of those before in real
life as far as side impacts.
Yeah.
I think they.
A lot of those cars have airbags and
shit now and they just.
Their pillars are designed to a certain
amount of impact and they give in with
stuff too.
I saw a car accident the other day
though at an intersection and it was a
dodge ram truck in like some little peon
Corolla.
Ooh.
They hadn't had on the Corolla was
destroyed and then when I see people
driving relative babies and tiny little
cars and the car seats like right next
door.
Yeah.
It's rather scary.
That's a scary one,
man.
One that'll fuck up.
You know what?
It's amazing.
That's your baby.
Think about how many cars are on the
road.
How rarely they slam into each other.
Most of the time people keep it
together.
Most of the time.
Most of the Times I kind of think the
traffic kind of filters out bad drivers
because bad drivers,
they're not going to laugh.
They're going to wreck,
so we'll usually.
We're left with people that have seen
rex and they're like,
you know,
once you've been in a wreck,
fuck,
you're super careful.
You know,
my mom was in a terrible wreck,
lost all her front teeth,
terrible wreck,
and she.
Since then,
this has been maybe 35 years.
She doesn't drive on the freeway.
She was like scared of death of the
freeway.
It was a horrible,
freely accident and she won't ever drive
on the freeway.
I've seen some bad ones and bad ones
coming home.
Late night from the comedy store,
cars flipped over,
smashed,
fucked up.
You know,
people are dead.
It happens.
I even get a full call to fucking drunks
anytime.
We're going to have a mad.
He was mad and it could happen to
anybody,
but he got hit by a train.
He got hit by a train.
He was trying to cross the train track.
I don't know what the whole story was,
but he got hit by a fucking train.
How's he doing right now?
Is Out of the coma apparently.
That's good.
Yeah.
He's responsive.
I mean if anybody's going to survive
something like that,
it's that fucking tank.
You know guys at tank.
I mean most.
Most people probably would have been
dead.
It's pretty amazing.
He was in a coma for quite a while.
And what's worth.
I mean getting attacked by a great white
shark and get eaten or well,
depends on what comes back from the car
wreck.
And he's like that dude from the dead
zone.
They could see the future.
Who holds your hands?
So you're going to run for your money on
John Jones.
Hold your hands.
You can see the future.
Right?
What does.
He just starts predicting fights and
he's.
Yeah.
How come this never that.
Like there were they talking about like
nuclear fallout.
How come no one's getting super powers?
Remember when you were a kid comic book,
if there was a nuclear accident,
you turned into the hulk when you turned
to spiderman.
It's a radioactive spider.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Today.
Every.
It's always bad.
There's no like others radiation.
Whereas yeah.
Where's all the mutations?
Where's the good mutations?
There's no good mutations.
No one ever has a good one.
No one ever becomes like Magneto,
right?
Yeah.
It's always like you're getting cancer.
There's all this new release cancer fall
out.
Where is it at?
You got to go to the places where it's
at.
You've received the video of a Shane
Smith from vice,
went to,
um,
went to Chernobyl and they,
they carrying around these radar
detectors are these radiation detectors.
It's off the charts,
man.
They got wolves running around.
They got cat fish.
They're swimming in the rivers
that are all mutated and giant.
Are they really mutated?
I,
I heard skeptical is.
I'm hearing that there is no mutations
and it's fake.
Fake News.
I Dunno.
I mean,
I don't know if you want to hear the
conspiracy thing.
I definitely don't.
Okay.
That's good.
Good thing,
man.
That's a good thing.
Radioactive catfish.
Um,
we've been doing like three and a half
hours.
Yeah.
It's already 5:15
mg per it.
Can they direct people to the replay?
Definitely.
The female flyweights was last night on
UFC fight pass.
You can catch the replay anytime.
You could watch all Ebi.
Ebi,
one through 12.
They're all up there.
We had our first all girl show,
including an all girl combat Jujitsu
tournament.
We had a regular 16 girl tournament it
totally with the people that were
predicted to win it.
They didn't even get close.
It was,
it was,
it was A.
I don't want to give it away.
Don't say anything but a boiler.
Yeah.
And we had a four woman combat Jujitsu
tournaments.
Have you seen that?
Have crazy Jujitsu with palm strikes to
the face and head and body or legal.
When you're on the ground standing,
it's just wrestling,
but on the ground,
as soon as someone hits the ground,
you could start palm striking to the
face.
Beautiful to the body.
So,
um,
we had,
uh,
for woman tournament it was nuts.
It was nuts.
Okay.
And then September ninth we're going to
be back.
That's going to be the next fight.
Companion.
I'm not doing that.
UFC,
that's UFC 2:15
in Edmonton.
So we'll be doing a fight companion
pumped this week.
Sacramento,
Thursday night,
Seattle,
Friday night.
And then San Diego Saturday night.
There's tickets,
tickets available for the second shows
and all three of those places.
Otherwise this whole program and we will
see you soon.
Okay,
bye.
Bye.
Mm.